ans est ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement
je souhaite la bienvenue dans notre
hémicycle au premier ministre et aux
membres du nouveau gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole la parole est à madame
virginie duby muller monsieur le premier
ministre puisqu'il me revient de vous
adresser la toute première question
d'actualité je vous exprime au nom de
mon groupe
nos félicitations républicaines pour
votre entrée en fonction je regrette
votre choix politique mais je souhaite
avant tout la réussite de la france et
donc le succès de votre gouvernement
en revanche j'ai beaucoup de mal à
imaginer comment vous allez pouvoir en
même temps mener votre politique est
resté fidèle à vos convictions
vous vous dites gaulliste social mais ne
nous y trompons pas votre gouvernement
penchera bien plus à gauche que vous
malgré vos tentatives peu réussie de
recrutement à droite c'est bien un
programme de gauche que vous allez
devoir appliquer monsieur le premier
ministre pourtant les français n'en
peuvent plus ils attendent un changement
de politique pas un recyclage de
ministre avec quelques têtes d'affiché
d'ailleurs les trois quarts de vos
ministres étaient déjà membres du
précédent gouvernement incapable de
réformer durablement le pays et ils ont
accentué les fractures économique
sociale et territoriale
comment avez vous pu vous féliciter dès
votre prise de fonction que la france
est l'un des taux de croissance les plus
élevés d'europe
en 2019 alors qu'elle était 24e sur 28
comment pouvez-vous vous inscrire dans
une politique migratoire laxiste ayant
fait entrer l'année dernière un record
de 276000 nouveaux immigrés légaux soit
49 % de plus que sous nicolas sarkozy
comment conduire une vraie réforme des
retraites et mettre en place une mesure
d'âge indispensable pour préserver les
pensions des français quand plusieurs de
vos ministres
ils sont ouvertement défavorable alors
répondez nous en vérité comme nouveau
capitaine du gouvernement avez vous le
courage de reconnaître que le cap
n'était pas le bon et qu'il est urgent
d'en changer je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
[Musique]
c
chiche s'il vous plaît seul le premier
ministre à la parole vous l'écoutez
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
je voudrais d'abord vous dire toute
l'émotion et tout l'honneur que je
ressens m'exprimant aujourd'hui pour la
première fois devant vous en ma qualité
de premier ministre devant la
représentation nationale
[Applaudissements]
sachez sachez que j'ai et que j'aurai
toujours un grand respect pour le
parlement et pour l'assemblée nationale
et pour l'assemblée nationale et que je
m'emploierai toujours vis-à-vis de vous
comme vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de la
nation a incarné les valeurs de respect
et de dialogue
madame la députée
jusque là tout va bien madame la députée
madame la députée il n'aura échappé à
personne et en particulier et en
particulier avoue même que ce nouveau
gouvernement entre en fonctions dans un
contexte très particulier une crise une
crise sanitaire d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle qui vous le savez n'est
pas terminée une crise économique et
sociale qui a déjà commencé et qui
s'annonce comme étant sans doute la plus
difficile que la france l'europe et le
monde auront à affronter depuis la crise
de 1929 avec madame la députée les
valeurs qui sont les miennes
avec les valeurs qui sont les miennes
j'ai l'honneur j'ai l'honneur de diriger
ce gouvernement qui sera un gouvernement
de combat qui sera un gouvernement
tourné vers l'efficacité qui sera un
gouvernement de dialogue qui sera un
gouvernement des territoires
parce que parce que cela ne répond pas
simplement à une conviction dans le
cadre des orientations dégagées par le
président de la république parce que
surtout ce sera un gage d'efficacité
pour lutter contre la crise
nous devrons être unis nous allons
engager un plan de relance ambitieux
nous allons engager un plan de relance
ambitieux qui sera à la fois marqué par
la nécessité de faire face au drame
humain au drame humain que vont
rencontrer des personnes et des
territoires et qui sera d'autant plus
efficients que dans la continuité de la
logique de transformation qui irriguent
ce quinquennat
nous investirons dans l'avenir la
transition écologique les territoires la
solidarité nationale le gouvernement
aujourd'hui constitué est tout au
service de ses ambitions
et je m'emploierai personnellement à
veiller aux résultats et à l'efficacité
de notre action au service de la france
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
calmez vous la parole ta madame la
présidente valérie rabault et elle seule
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre le président de la
république vous a confié je le cite la
responsabilité de tracer un nouveau
chemin pour notre pays
pensez vous que ce nouveau chemin soit
compatible avec le maintien de la
réforme des retraites
en clair monsieur le premier ministre
maintiendrez vous oui ou non une réforme
à laquelle 61 % des français sont
opposés
une réforme injuste qui divisent les
français fragilise un très grand nombre
d'entre eux au moment monsieur le
premier ministre où la france doit faire
pâques pour se relancer
je vous remercie la parole à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur président à
madame la présidente je viens de le dire
à l'instant
la crise est clair le nouveau chemin
qu'a annoncé le président de la
république nous devons impérativement
tenir compte de ce nouveau contexte pour
l'ensemble des chambres de l'action
gouvernementale au premier rang desquels
la réforme des retraites que vous venez
d'évoquer je voudrais préciser devant la
représentation nationale
la façon dont mon gouvernement va
aborder ce sujet dans les semaines et
les mois à venir
dès cette semaine je recevrai l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux qui seront avant
le 20 juillet réunit de façon collective
dans une conférence de méthode
mon objectif est de mettre tous les
sujets sur la charge
je commence par vous dire que la santé
je souhaite régler en large par le sujet
dans le cadre du ségur cette semaine
avec des négociations conduites sous
l'égide du ministre de la santé et dans
lesquels je suis intervenu dès hier pour
demander à ce que l'effort considérable
est méritée et justifier que la nation
doit faire pour les soignants en terme
de salaire soit complétée et vous le
savez en vos qualités d'élu de terrain
par des créations d'emplois dans les
établissements de santé la santé les
retraites la dépendance l'assurance
chômage
le plan de relance tout sera mis sur la
table
nous allons écouter et concertée seule
cette méthode sera efficace
madame la députée nous nous retrouverons
avec les partenaires sociaux pour
décider à la rentrée ce qui relève de la
négociation et de la concertation
s'agissant des retraites j'y viens oui
mais mesdames et messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés
vous le savez vous le savez aucun sujet
si important soit-il ne peut être
traitée efficacement
s'il n'est pas éclairé d'une cohérence
d'ensemble de l'action gouvernementale
pour les retraites et j'en termine
madame la députée il a d'ores et déjà
été actée que nous distingue riom les
concertations à reprendre sur la réforme
de forme à laquelle nous ne renoncerons
pas sur un système de retraites plus
juste plus juste
qu'attendent de leurs voeux tous les
français en revanche nous le sépareront
nous le sépare au rang des dispositions
qu'il y a lieu de prendre pour
sauvegarder le système actuel et qu'on
venait toutes et tous avec moi que la
situation financière de ce système n'est
pas tout à fait la même
depuis qu'il subit lui aussi de plein
fouet l'impact de la crise économique
qui pourrait surtout les bancs de cette
assemblée
indépendamment de ce que vous pensez du
futur régime laisser s'effondrer le
système de retraite actuel
nous devons donc en responsabilité et
avec les partenaires sociaux et dans un
cadre concerté prendre les dispositions
nécessaires pour assurer la sauvegarde
merci madame la présidente vous avez la
parole
seul premier ministre je vais précoce
l'inspirent de remarque d'abord tous les
partenaires sociaux y compris ceux qui
étaient favorables à la réforme des
retraites sont contre le maintien de
cette réforme dans le contexte actuel
tous vous êtes tout seul
monsieur le premier ministre contre les
partenaires sociaux au delà au delà
au delà cette réforme maintenir cette
réforme relève de l'irresponsabilité
monsieur le premier ministre
plutôt que relancer un débat sur les
retraites fait le plan de relance ça
fait 15 jours que l'assemblée est bloqué
sur le plan de relance que vous avez
annoncé
d'après les estimations que nous avons
la france est le pays l'union européenne
qui subit qui subit la détérioriation de
son pib le plus importante colmater
cette chute nécessite deux choses
monsieur le premier ministre
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat les
allemands l'ont fait ils ont donné 300
euros par enfant dans votre gouvernement
il n'y a eu aucun soutien pour la
demande des ménages
nous vous avons proposé nous vous avons
proposé ici 250 euros par famille plus
100 euros
vous avez dit non
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre il faut un plan de
relance économique qui traite les trois
urgences écologiques sociales et
économiques
vous avez refusé la prime climat que
nous vous avons proposé
c'est elle qui peut faire de la relance
isère si madame la présidente
la parole est à monsieur stanislas
guérini
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
permettez moi tout d'abord au nom de la
république en marche de vous féliciter
ainsi que votre gouvernement nommé vous
n'ignorez rien des difficultés de
l'ampleur de la crise que nous avons
affronté mais je suis certain que vous
serez faire face avec le sens de l'état
et de l'intérêt général
permettez moi également de rendre
hommage à l'action du gouvernement
sortant
conduite par votre prédécesseur edouard
philippe et à travers eux
l'action qui a été menée par cette
majorité pendant trois ans pour mettre
en oeuvre les réformes voulues par le
président de la république
mais aujourd'hui monsieur le premier
ministre je veux parler d'avenir de
l'avenir de notre pays c'est à dire de
sa jeunesse
cette jeunesse qui a montré sa capacité
à se mobiliser pendant la crise
sanitaire pour aider pour être utile
notamment aux personnes âgées celles que
l'on regarde parfois avec inquiétude
quand elle manifeste sa colère
alors qu'elle demande avant tout qu'on
lui offre un avenir un avenir où elle
n'est pas à payer toutes nos dettes
financières mais aussi écologique un
avenir où l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes ne soient pas
simplement un principe un avenir avec
des perspectives de formation et
d'emploi
la république en marche a formulé de
nombreuses propositions pour que dès la
rentrée 2020 aucun jeune ne soit laissée
sans solution que tous puissent disposer
d'une activité n'a revenu d'un
accompagnement
bref que la génération de kobe 19 ne
soit pas une génération sacrifiée
vous avez nommé un gouvernement de
combat vous l'avez rappelé alors battons
nous aussi pour donner un avenir à nos
enfants ils doivent être au coeur du
nouveau pacte social que nous avons à
écrire au coeur de la promesse
républicaines de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité au coeur de notre projet
alors monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous dès à présent nous dira si
la jeunesse constituera une priorité du
plan de relance que vous êtes en train
de préparer
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la balle est à
monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
et je vous serais reconnaissant d'éviter
les bavardages qui crée un brouhaha qui
rendent difficile d'écouter les
questions et en formant les réponses
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président ai-je besoin de
rappeler à la représentation nationale
et qu' il y a huit millions de jeunes en
france 12 % de la population c'est à
dire et c'est une chance une force l'un
des taux les plus élevés d'europe
deuxième élément de données chiffrées
dans les semaines et mois à venir à la
rentrée
entre 700 et 800 mille jeunes vont se
présenter comme on dit sur le marché du
travail et en même temps par l'effet de
la crise par l'effet de la crise
c'est à peu près le nombre d'emplois que
celle-ci 700000 a déjà détruit cette
considération nous fixent ensemble
la première obligation qui sera au coeur
du plan de relance à savoir apporter à
notre jeunesse
dans ce contexte fortement dégradé des
réponses en termes de formation de
qualification et d'emploi je rappelle
que le précédent gouvernement et la
majorité ont déjà beaucoup agi en la
matière
l'obligation de formation jusqu'à 18 ans
va entrer en vigueur le 1er septembre
prochain
il y a la garantie jeunes il y a le plan
d'investissement des compétences et
notamment sa dimension pour les plus
jeunes il y a
l'augmentation très forte des entrées en
apprentissage d'ores et déjà réalisée
grâce à l'action conduite par muriel
pénicaud
il y a plus récemment l'aide
exceptionnelle destinée à un million
deux cent mille jeunes dans la crise du
code vite et bien les dispositions du
plan de relance que nous préparons
équivaut qui vous seront soumises
prochainement iront plus fort et plus
loin dans le registre de la formation et
de l'entrée dans l'emploi des jeunes
la deuxième la deuxième préoccupation
qui est la nôtre concerne la transition
écologique vous le savez parfaitement
mesdames et messieurs les députés
c'est un sujet qui à bon droit nous
passionne à toutes et à tous mais
davantage encore les plus jeunes
nous devons être ambitieux madame la
ministre vous le serez en la matière est
associée là aussi dans les territoires
le maximum de jeunes pour leur donner
l'occasion concrètement concrètement de
favoriser la transition écologique de
notre pays et les ambitions que nous
portons enfin mon gouvernement dans la
continuité du précédent entend accroître
l'ensemble des dispositifs de lutte
contre les discriminations et de relance
de l'ascenseur social troisième
préoccupation majeure de la jeunesse de
notre pays
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et top s'il vous plaît voilà on
écoute maintenant monsieur alain brunel
qui seul à la parole merci monsieur le
président le groupe de
télécommunications nokia a annoncé son
intention de supprimer 1230 trois
emplois en france soit un tiers de ses
effectifs
c'est le quatrième plan social depuis le
rachat d'acs at-elle du sang par nokia
en 2016 alors que nokia a perçu 280
millions d'euros de crédit impôt
recherche
c'est la recherche et le développement
qui est sacrifiée par le groupe au
risque de voir disparaître le dernier
constructeur d'équipements télécoms en
france à l'heure où l'on parle de
reconquête de notre souveraineté
industrielle
l'état ne peut rester l'armé au pied
devant ce nouveau plan de casse de
l'emploi à l'heure où air france prévoit
de supprimer 7000 600 emplois que sanofi
annonce la suppression d'un millier de
postes en france que qu'un plan social
menace 5000 emplois chez airbus que
renault annonce de 4600 suppressions
d'emplois l'état doit prendre ses
responsabilités
il est indispensable de maintenir de
transformer et de développer nous outils
industriels afin de préparer l'avenir
les entreprises dont nous parlons ont
reçu des milliards d'euros d' aides
publiques
le gouvernement ne saurait accepter que
les salariés de ces entreprises
stratégiques soit sacrifié la relance
économique ne peut se faire sur le dos
des salariés et pour le seul profit de
la poignée d'ultra riches auquel le
gouvernement fait toujours les yeux de
chimène le monde d'après exige de
changer de braquet
la question du groupe communiste et
simple monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous me garantir qu'il n'y aura
aucune casse sociale et qu'aucun salarié
ne restera sur le carreau qu'elle garde
fous allez-vous mettre en place merci
chers collègues la parole qu'à madame
agnès pannier rue lâché ministre chargé
de l'industrie
[Musique]
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député bruyneel vous parlez
de la politique industrielle et vous
savez que ce gouvernement a été
particulièrement en pointe sur la
politique industrielle depuis trois ans
vous savez que ce gouvernement est celui
qui lui succède
que ce gouvernement a fait en sorte et
que cette majorité de recréer de
l'emploi industriel sur les territoires
donc non non nous sommes nous en action
pour effectivement faire en sorte de
limiter la casse sociale à un moment
inédit de crise mondiale sur l'activité
économique et l'activité industrielle en
particulier cette politique industrielle
elle va être au coeur de notre relance
monsieur brunel au coeur de notre
relancer ça d'ailleurs été le premier
déplacement du premier ministre dans une
entreprise industrielle
vous mentionnez un certain nombre de
dossiers et vous avez bien raison ces
dossiers nous les suivons de près
parlons de sanofi sanofi c'est un plan
d'évolution des effectifs
il n'y aura aucun départ contraint je
veux vous rassurer
et moi je veux saluer aussi
l'investissement de 600 millions d'euros
de sanofi dans une usine à vaccin à
marcy l'étoile qui vient d'être annoncée
en juin et je peux vous dire que j'ai
obtenu de la part des dirigeants de
sanofi qu'il maintienne à moyen terme
l'emploi sur la france voir qu il le
développe donc oui nous sommes à la
manoeuvre
vous parlez de nokia qui je partage
totalement votre préoccupation et
d'ailleurs je sais que des députés sont
aujourd'hui mobilisés aux côtés des
salariés de nokia entre montparnasse et
invalides
maintenant le député bothorel la députée
rixin pour ne citer que ces deux là
le président de région monsieur loïg
chesnais-girard et nous sommes à la
manoeuvre pour trouver des solutions car
il ne s'agit pas d'invectivés
il s'agit de trouver des solutions il
s'agit de bâtir une industrie qui soit
compétitive et qui rentraient l'emploi
en france
la parole est à monsieur le président
olivier belge
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
permettez moi d'abord de féliciter
monsieur le premier ministre et
l'ensemble de son gouvernement pour leur
domination et leur souhaiter bon courage
au nom des députés agir ensemble dans
leur mission
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
concerne le service ferroviaire pendant
la crise du coc vie de la sncf a
considérablement ralenti ses cadences
qui était parfaitement compréhensible
lorsque nous étions confinés
aujourd'hui le service a repris mais pas
dans son intégralité c'est encore un
service adapté qui parfois est inférieur
de 30% au service normal sur certaines
lignes
cela pose trois problèmes un premier
pour les françaises et les français qui
galère au quotidien pour se rendre à
leur travail
un second problème au moment de la
relance économique pour faire en sorte
que tous les territoires y compris ceux
qui sont concernés par le tourisme
puisse être desservis et enfin une
troisième difficulté en termes
d'aménagement du territoire et je sais
monsieur le premier ministre que vous
êtes extrêmement sensible à cette
question d' équilibre des territoires
pour l'attractivité et la compétitivité
ça pose d'ailleurs une question en
termes de développement durable puisque
si nous souhaitons supprimer les
liaisons aériennes plus courte il faut
encore que tous les territoires puissent
être relié qui à part le faire a
rapidement aux grandes métropoles mais
également aux aéroports internationaux
cas je rêve
bien entendu que la sncf redevienne ce
grand fleuron national qu'elle est
qu'elle était autrefois je rêve même un
jour qu'elle puisse atteindre le niveau
de performance et de ponctualité à la
japonaise
mais dans l'immédiat il faut déjà
récupéré le service que nous avions
avant la crise du que vides
pouvez vous monsieur le mini et le
premier ministre intervenir auprès du
directeur de la sncf afin que nos
concitoyens puissent se retrouver
rapidement un service de train normal
merci
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président président
olivier becht mesdames et messieurs les
députés
merci de cette question le la reprise de
l'activité du transport ferroviaire que
j'ai tout particulièrement suivis
pendant les semaines précédentes dans le
cadre de la mission que m'avait confié
le précédent gouvernement sur le dé
confinement est marqué par la volonté de
faire redémarrer notre économie dont les
transports sont leurs des vecteurs de
faire redémarrer la vie quotidienne de
la nation tout en assurant les
protections sanitaires dus aux voyageurs
c'est ce que nous avons fait je rappelle
à chacune et à chacun que pendant la
période du confinement
vous l'avez dit monsieur le député cette
activité a été particulièrement réduite
mais depuis la mi juin environ
l'offre de tgv et de trains intercités
est revenu proche de la normale
même les trains de nuit ont recommencé à
circuler la semaine dernière il n'en
reste pas moins
il n'en reste pas moins que le taux de
réservation en particulier des tgv est
encore proche de 50% ce qui a conduit la
sncf à adapter son offre
ne doutez pas de notre volonté
incarnée par monsieur le ministre des
transports de voir revenir
l'activité du service public ferroviaire
dans les toutes prochaines semaines et
si possible dans les tout prochains
jours
à la normale j'en profite pour vous
rappeler combien le transport
ferroviaire constitue une priorité de
cette majorité
nous avons nous avons ensemble et avec
les région autorité organisatrice
considérer que la priorité était à la
régénération du réseau partout sur le
territoire
en dégageant à ce sujet des efforts
inédits et bien entendu dans le cadre de
la transition écologique
nous allons poursuivre et amplifier ses
efforts je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est un monsieur antoine
savinien je vous remercie monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la justice de
longue date je me félicite de partager
la même vision que vous de notre système
judiciaire est sans aller jusqu'à
qualifier de barbouzes les magistrats du
parquet je dois admettre qu'il ya
matière à réflexion mais ici sachez que
nous sommes très seul l'oralité
judiciaire n'a plus lieu d'exister en
modernise en informatisant automatise
bref on déshumanise la justice les
défenseurs des cours criminelles sont
légion et nous sommes peu nombreux à
nous être élevés contre cette terrible
expérimentation donc monsieur le
ministre
bienvenue dans l'opposition vos
déclarations passées ne peuvent que
réchauffer nos coeurs tant il est vrai
que depuis deux ans et demi nous nous
sentons seuls dans l'appréhension de ce
que devrait être notre justice mais
avant pourriez vous nous éclairer
vous ne deviez jamais occupé ce fauteuil
et vous êtes là vous ne deviez jamais
avalé de couleuvres et vous avez retiré
votre plainte pour cette atteinte
inadmissible à votre vie privée et au
secret professionnel
alors monsieur le ministre vos actions
futures seront elles en adéquation avec
vos déclarations passées ou pas
merci la parole est à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Musique]
vous avez la parole un peu de silence
s'il vous plaît non vous avez raison on
n'est pas au spectacle et je vais
répondre à la question que me posent
monsieur le le député d'abord vous savez
tous que quand on est avocat pénaliste
libre on n'a pas la même parole que
quand on représente l'état ça n'échappe
à personne
avez vous toujours dit la même chose
c'est vrai qu'à un moment j'ai dit que
je n'accepterais pas cette tâche toi tu
y avoir une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'années on va mettre un terme définitif
non je vous en prie le sait déjà c'est
déjà compliqué pour moi c'est là c'est
une première mais
[Applaudissements]
ces lvps laissez moi monsieur le député
j'ai un sens aigu du contradictoire et
du respect de la parole de l'autre
j'aimerais que vous me laissiez au moins
m'exprimer au pardonnez moi on ne juge
on ne les monsieur le député je voudrais
vous répondre complètement
on ne juge pas des hommes sur des a
priori me semble-t-il
vous me jugerez sur ce que j'ai fait
quand je l'aurais fait et pardonnez moi
pardonnez moi vous je vais vous dire
quelque chose quand on est haut quand on
est au café du commerce on ne s'exprime
pas alors comme quand on est avocat
quand on est avocat on ne s'exprime pas
comme quand on est ministre ça c'est
pour la forme
moi au 15 mai au café du commerce je ne
porte pas de cravate à l'assemblée j'en
ai une
voilà alors je vais vous répondre
je je je je vais vous rép
et est ce qu on décompte les
interventions des combats à ben voilà on
souffre en silence mais je ferais bien
cela fait trois fois major était celle
d'un homme libre ma parole sera celle du
ministre de ce gouvernement
je remercie je tiens à vous le dire tout
choses très très vite
le président de la république et
monsieur le premier ministre la
confiance qu'ils m'accordent je veux
travailler avec vous tous députés
députés de la majorité comme député de
l'opposition
encore un mot monsieur je sais qu'il est
possible parce que l'idée que l'on se
fait de la justice
continuez
[Applaudissements]
là l'idée l'idée monsieur le député que
l'on se fait de la justice vous me
l'accorderez transcende les clivages
j'ai vécu la commission d' enquête
parlementaire d'outreau
à ma gauche il y avait si vous me
permettez ce mauvais jeu de mots le
député marceau monsieur ou lyon monsieur
vallini sensibilités politiques
différentes
82 propositions on peut tous travailler
ensemble
voilà magazine jamais
monsieur le député merci monsieur roux
pierre lescoutte monsieur merci monsieur
le président merci monsieur le ministre
avoue que je reste un peu sur ma faim
mais j'entends votre appel et le fait
que nous puissions tous travailler
ensemble
j'espère que vous n'oublierez pas non
plus la gelée juridiction civile
commerciale prud'homale administrative
le rôle du conseil d'état aussi dans nos
institutions
au jour d'aujourd'hui parce que tout
cela est particulièrement important
et comme vous l'avez dit à juste titre
vous voyez l'exercice change il n'est
pas si simple
ici les mots ne sont plus rien les
français ont besoin d'action ils
jugeront vos actes et je vous souhaite
bon courage et d'être très bon merci
chers collègues la parole peuvent
l'amener ateliers les moeurs merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre c'est dans l'adn du
modem depuis toujours de défendre la
famille et cela fait maintenant trois
ans que notre groupe milite sans relâche
en faveur d'une politique familiale
ambitieuse moderne et efficace
c'est pourquoi nous regrettons de ne pas
la voir dans l'architecturé du nouveau
gouvernement
et ce d'autant que la crise sanitaire a
mis les familles à rude épreuve
elles sont réapparus pour ce qu'elles
sont une valeur refuge
berceau des solidarités et pilier de
notre cohésion sociale les inégalités de
notre système ont également été mises en
exergue et nous devons maintenant lui
redonner justice lisibilité simplicité
de manière pérenne au delà des mesures
d'urgence porté par le gouvernement
pendant la crise
la mission d'information sur
l'adaptation de la politique familiale
française aux défis du 21e siècle dont
je suis rapporteur a rendu ses
conclusions la semaine dernière et
j'aurai l'honneur de vous remettre
prochainement ce rapport il est
largement soutenue sur tous les bancs
mais également dans les territoires par
les français et par les associations
familiales
ils portent 40 propositions fortes
visant au premier chef à mieux protéger
les familles à leur redonner du pouvoir
d'achat et à leur offrir toutes les
conditions d'un plein épanouissement
nous devons assumer une véritable
politique nataliste enjeux
démographiques fondamental pour la
société française de demain en
particulier face au défi de la
dépendance
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la croisée des
chemins alors qu'une politique familiale
renforcer constituerait un puissant
outil économique
un statu quo ne ferait que rajouter de
la crise à la crise
alors monsieur le premier ministre
question simple quelle place pour la
famille lien quelle politique familiale
comptez vous mener pour qu'elle ne soit
plus les grandes oubliées de ce
quinquennat je vous remercie
la parole à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame madame la députée nathalie l
image je vous remercie pour votre
question importante qui met en exergue
l'importance de la politique familiale
dans un pays comme la france
je salue la qualité de vos travaux nous
avons eu l'occasion de débattre ensemble
est tombé d'ailleurs souvent d'accord
lorsque j'étais parlementaire à vos
côtés dans le cadre des exercices
budgétaires et il ya eu des missions
conjointes d'ailleurs qui ont associé
des députés et des oppositions je salue
aussi notamment le député du rpt ton
pour la constance de son travail sur la
politique familiale et le député
guillaume schiste qui avait également
sur un autre monde cette assemblée émis
des recommandations de bref la question
de la famille elle transcende également
la caisse les clivages politiques
la politique familiale pays ce sont 50
milliards d'euros par an 50 milliards
d'euros par an de prestations qui sont
versés à plus de 6,6 millions de
familles les familles nous les avons
soutenu madame la députée limaces en
particulier au coeur de la crise virale
avec une aide 450 millions d'euros qui
ont été apportées pour faire vivre les
structures d'accueil de jeunes enfants
la politique familiale
ça va bien au delà des crédits c'est
l'éducation des enfants c'est les 1000
jours le premier des huit jours qui a
été initiée par adrien taquet c'est
l'accueil le soutien aux familles
parental les modifications des schémas
des familles dans notre pays je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont 23 % des familles
qui sont monoparentales les familles du
21ème siècle ne sont plus les mêmes
modèles famille que celle du 20è siècle
il ya également la question de
l'homoparentalité qui est à prendre en
compte
et puis toutes les prestations qui
doivent être versés pour permettre de
briser ces inégalités sociales à la
racine
lorsque l'enfant est tout petit le
soutien aux parents le soutien à
l'éducation
beaucoup de mesures transcende
d'ailleurs le simple champ de la
politique familiale madame la députée
quand on dédouble les classes les
effectifs dans l'est dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire on mène aussi
une petite familiale efficace bref je
vous rejoins sur l'importance vitale de
soutenir la parentalité de soutenir les
familles dans notre pays
quelles que soient les façons d'ailleurs
de le faire vous avez devant vous le
ministre en charge de ces questions j'en
suis très heureux très fier et je me
réjouis de pouvoir travailler avec vous
dans les mois à venir
merci monsieur vie ni madame le député
merci monsieur le ministre
en tout cas je vous invite à lire le
rapport qui comprend de nombreuses
mesures la politique familiale forte
depuis ce a été forte dans notre pays
pendant sa plus de 60 ans et ella ella
portée elle a porté ses fruits
elle a subi des coups de rabot on en
voit aujourd'hui les conséquences en
tout cas nous serons toujours aux côtés
du gouvernement si longtemps la
promouvoir
et sinon nous continuerons à nous battre
merci à mme la députée la parole est à
monsieur jean hugues ratenon
si monsieur le président mais ce
monsieur le premier ministre c'est on
c'est surréaliste puisque ne pouvant
vous interprétez au titre de votre
politique générale à venir
je souhaite alors vous entende en votre
qualité d'aix monsieur déconfinement
concernant les outre-mer qui n'est pas
une souffrance mais bien la france dès
le début du conte vide associations
syndicats collectifs de citoyens et ong
ont alerté le gouvernement sur les
spécificités des territoires d'outre-mer
les défaillances structurelles la
pauvreté et la précarité dans ces
territoires ont été ignorés et
aujourd'hui ce sont les populations qui
en paie le prix le prix fort en guyane à
mayotte depuis le mois d'avril la
situation sanitaire est devenu de plus
en plus inquiétante
l'épidémie flanc le nombre de malades le
nombre de morts augmente qu'avez vous
fait pour éviter cela pire vous regarder
ailleurs et autoriser les vols
commerciaux entre mayotte et la réunion
sans réel plan de protection des
habitants en martinique ce sont les
médecins cubains qui débarque en renfort
à la place de l'état français
et on les remercie mais où sont nos
médecins français en guadeloupe c'est la
double peine
en plus du coc vide elle fait face un
facteur très aggravant le manque d'eau
potable
est ce digne d'un département français
en 2020 devant nos territoires
abandonnés
le 1er avril le député européen younous
omarjee a dû solliciter l'aide de
l'union européenne
à la réunion c'est l'explosion des colis
alimentaires
conséquence d'une économie fragile et de
la provôté qui s'aggrave
notamment chez les personnes âgées où
est la dignité
aujourd'hui survie sur le gâteau vous
n'avez trouvé aucune femme aucun homme
d'outre-mer d'inga vosges et occuper la
fonction de ministre
est ce la veut d'abandon des outre-mer
ou alors allez vous apporter de vraies
réponses aux problèmes posés
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur sébastien lecornu ministre d
outre-mer merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député ratenon je vous le dis comme
je le pense je ne pense pas que vous
rendez service aux territoires
d'outre-mer
en remontant les collectivités
territoriales les habitants de ces
territoires contre l'état l'état a
répondu présent dans cette crise du
mieux qu'il a pu
la communauté des soignants c'est l'état
les policiers c'est l'état les gendarmes
c'est l'état les pompiers c'est l'état
donc
rendez-leur aux marges remercier les est
considéré que sous l'autorité du premier
ministre du gouvernement d'edouard
philippe précède un mort de jean castex
aujourd'hui la mobilisation était totale
je vais vous dire monsieur le député
vous n'êtes pas votre première
contrevérité près je vous disais il ya
deux jours vous preniez à témoins
l'ensemble des maires de la réunion pour
leur expliquer que cette majorité
parlementaire diminuer le concours du
gouvernement de l'état pardon aux
collectivités territoriales la dgf aller
stable depuis 2010 est mieux que cela
elle augmente dès cette année pour
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales d'outre-mer
vous êtes conseiller municipal de bras
panon la dgf augmentent de 4% cette
année
donc si on veut y arriver pour les
territoires d'outre-mer consacrons-nous
aux vraies difficultés et arrêtons de
colporter des contrevérités
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
cava dames emilie chanas merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique
avant toute chose je souhaiterais vous
féliciter et vous apporter tout mon
soutien tout notre soutien à votre
nomination au poste de ministre de la
transition écologique
madame la ministre
lundi 29 juin dernier le président
recevait à l'elysée les membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
s'engage et à transmettre au
gouvernement et au parlement 146
propositions je tiens ici à saluer à mon
tour le travail de ces 150 citoyens en
matière d'écologie
nous devons aller plus vite plus fort
plus loin deux chemins se dessine dans
le paysage politique français
celui de l'écologie dogmatique de
l'extrême gauche punitive décroissante
qui laisse au bord du chemin les
questions de l'emploi et des solidarités
et il ya celui que je choisis une
écologie progressiste positive inclusive
enthousiasmante et pragmatique qui
pensent que l'utilité de la 5g mérite
d'être explorée sans postures
démagogiques sortir de la communication
dire la vérité aux français
être lucide et ambitieux les
propositions de la convention citoyenne
riche et audacieuse dépendent pour
nombre d'entre elles des collectivités
territoriales comme la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments la limitation
des constructions dans la nature le
développement des circuits courts
l'engagement des mobilités moins
polluantes la protection de l'écosystème
ou encore la participation citoyenne
tout ne passe pas tous ne passent plus
par l'état nous le savons les élus
locaux sont un maillon essentiel de la
transition écologique qui doit se faire
en grande partie au niveau des
territoires
dans son allocution du dimanche 10 10 14
juin par dont le président de la
république annoncé vouloir ouvrir une
nouvelle page des relations entre l'état
et les territoires en donnant des
libertés et des responsabilités inédite
aux élus locaux
madame la ministre comment le
gouvernement compte-t-il articulé en
même temps la mise en place des mesures
fortes en matière environnementale à
l'échelle locale et de nouvelles
missions pour nos maires et présidents
territoire merci on a bien débuté la
parole et à madame barbara pompili
ministre de la transition et que merci
merci merci monsieur le président merci
chers collègues je vais encore avoir du
mal à passer de l'autre côté merci chers
collègues michel dont je connais
l'investissement sur le territoire
grenoblois et dont j'attends beaucoup de
soutien tout d'abord un petit mot pour
dire que je me sens quand même un petit
peu ému d'être là dans notre maison
commune que j'aime tant que j'aime tant
et où je sais que je compte beaucoup
d'amis et de soutien je remercie
beaucoup
monsieur le président de la république
et monsieur le premier ministre pour
leur confiance dans cette tâche que je
sais lourde que je sais est immense et
où je sais je vous plaît je suis très
attendu et que je suis très attendue par
tout le monde
je mesure complètement l'immensité de la
tâche
je mesure la tente je mesure les énormes
obstacles mais je mesure aussi l'immense
volonté que j'ai de faire bouger les
choses et faire bouger les choses
faire bouger les choses je n'y arriverai
pas tout seul et je sais et je sais
parce que j'en ai eu l'assurance et j'en
remercie premier ministre je sais que je
vais pouvoir compter sur l'ensemble du
gouvernement
je sais que je vais pouvoir compter sur
une équipe sur une équipe qui sera là
pour me soutenir et qui sera là pour
avancer avec moi dans le plan de relance
pour avancer avec moi dans l'application
des mesures proposées par la convention
citoyenne pour le climat je vais avoir
avec moi évidemment elisabeth borne à
qui je succède et que je remercie
tellement pour son travail
je vais avoir avec moi bruno le maire
pour la relance économique
je vais avoir avec moi julien de
normandie sur l'agriculture je vais
avoir avec moi évidemment au sein de mon
ministère emmanuelle wargon et
jean baptiste djebbari sur nos logements
sur nos transports sur les outre mer
évidemment je vais avoir sébastien
lecornu sur la mère annick girardin
bref je viens voir du monde et je vais
vous en mars ou en mai
merci beaucoup
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence la
parole est à monsieur julien dive
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à julien de normandie
que je souhaite aussi féliciter pour sa
nomination comme ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous confirmer que c'est
bien un ingénieur agronome qui fixera la
doctrine de la politique agricole
nationale et non le dogmatisme rampant
qui a tort a nourri jusqu'à aujourd'hui
la grille bashing et qui figure déjà sur
ses bancs pour vous amener à répondre je
vous propose de vous engager sur un
sujet d'actualité sur lequel le
président de la république a lui-même
voulu prendre date l'interdiction du
glyphosate en france ce sujet épineux
provoque un doublé mois dans notre
société
d'un côté l'aspiration des consommateurs
par rapport à l'utilisation de ces
terres by side qui n'est pas appliquée
contrairement aux idées reçues sur des
cultures alimentaires en place et de
l'autre la crainte et les inquiétudes
des agriculteurs français face à
l'absence d'alternative durable et
respectueuse de l'environnement ainsi
que de moyens financiers je rappelle que
contrairement à beaucoup de leurs
homologues en europe et dans le monde
nos paysans respectent des règles
données des normes environnementales et
sanitaires bien plus exigeante
pour l'instant ce débat n'a réussi
qu'une seule chose
dresser les consommateurs contre les
agriculteurs une annonce étant toujours
plus simple quand elle n'est pas
expliqué j'ai donc des questions claires
en espérant des réponses tout aussi
clair monsieur le ministre afin que tout
le monde sache aujourd'hui ce qu'il en
est
quelle est la date de l'interdiction du
glyphosate en france nos agriculteurs
ont besoin de visibilité et le temps
semble compté proposez-vous des
dérogations
si oui allez voulait fonder sur un type
de culture en situation d'impasse
ou alors sur une conduite culturale
quelle alternative mettez vous sur la
table pour eux et avec quels
financements rendre accessible une
alimentation saine et de qualité pour
tous c'est aussi rappelé l'effort fourni
par les filières si vous mettez des
règles supplémentaires pour nos
agriculteurs
mettez aussi des moyens pour les
accompagner c'est à vous de trouver les
alternatives qui tiennent compte de leur
réalité
il en va de notre sécurité alimentaire
et de
puissance agricole merci chers collègues
la parole quand monsieur julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
[Musique]
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député julien dive
ce sera l'ingénieur agronome qui va vous
répondre
jamais de dogmatisme et je crois que
cela est partagée par beaucoup
vous savez pendant la période qu'on a
vécu les français ont pu compter sur
l'agriculture ont pu compter sur les
agriculteurs sur les éleveurs sur les
pêcheurs
cette deuxième ligne et je crois que
nous devons beaucoup à notre agriculture
nous leur devons beaucoup parce qu'ils
ont tenue nous leur devons beaucoup
parce que c'est une part de notre
identité nous leur devons beaucoup parce
que c'est un formidable secteurs
d'activité économique et nous leur
devons beaucoup également dans
l'accompagnement face aux défis aux
défis techniques technologiques et aux
défis écologiques comme la transition
avec les produits phytosanitaires alors
s'agissant de votre question je vais
être très clair la première question
c'est sûr l'objectif de sortie du
glyphosate
le président de la république a été très
clair là dessus il a fixé des objectifs
temporels en disant que ses objectifs
temporels devait s'appliquer aux regards
également des produits de substitution
parce que l'accompagnement de nos
agriculteurs
il est absolument indispensable le
deuxième c'est que nous le ferons avec
méthode et je peux vous dire que cette
méthode
à mes yeux elle est absolument essentiel
cette mobilisation d'accompagnement deux
ministères du ministère de l'écologie
des agences de l'ensemble des acteurs et
des parlementaires qui sont énormément
mobilisés sur la question et puis le
troisième élément et je m'engage dessus
c'est la transparence et cette
transparence je sais monsieur le député
vous l'appelez de vos voeux on a par
exemple avec la majorité présidentielle
demandé un recensement près d'un tiers
on rendra lé résultat public très
prochainement
près d'un tiers des exploitations sont
déjà sortis du glyphosate un autre et un
autre tiers sont en train de sortir du
glyphosate et tous ces résultats nous
les rendrons
public pour montrer l'évolution y
compris sur les achats objectifs
maintenus mer séparant si les messages à
sa la libre parole est à monsieur boris
vallot monsieur le premier ministre il
ya entre le gaullisme social et le
maquereau nisme total une différence de
nature de morale et de méthodes et vous
avez indiquée
depuis votre prise de fonction vouloir
laisser une place plus importante au
dialogue social et vous recevez dans
quelques heures les partenaires sociaux
vous avez l'occasion de les entendre
la cfdt la cgt force ouvrière la cftc la
cfe cgc chez cgc la fsu l'unsa ont
indiqué avec netteté le medef aussi
qu'il fallait retirer la réforme des
retraites qui n'était pas tant de
remettre de la tension et que notre
énergie devait être consacrée à l'emploi
a sauvé nos entreprises face à la
multiplication des plans sociaux et
qu'il aurait t-il répondu que vous leur
été réglé à court terme cette affaire de
retraite en est que le président parle
d'un allongement de la durée de
cotisation que doit-on comprendre
monsieur le premier ministre la cfdt la
cgt force ouvrière la cftc cfe cgc
l'unsa la fsu ont été indiqués honte
indiqué qu' il était temps de retirer la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui avait
fait déjà beaucoup de dégâts et qui en
ferait encore beaucoup si l'obstination
déraisonnable du gouvernement devait
l'emporter sur la raison sociale
nous devons consacrer notre énergie à
l'emploi à la jeunesse à l'insertion à
la pauvreté et que leur est-il en même
temps répondu eh bien que les français
auraient une préférence pour le chômage
au moment où tant d'entre eux sauf
menacés dans leur emploi il faut confier
aux partenaires sociaux le soin de
négocier une réforme de l'assurance
chômage avec des principes conformes à
notre temps monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez dit ne pas croire au consensus
nous ne croyons pas aux 10 ans us dur
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
dire que vous avez entendu les
partenaires sociaux tous les partenaires
sociaux et que vous allez retirer la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et la
réforme de retraites et vous mettre au
travail pour le plan de relance
la parole est à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
e
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
boris vallot je voudrais tout d'abord
vous remercier pour votre question qui
me donne l'occasion d'exprimer devant la
représentation nationale
ma reconnaissance au président de la
république et au premier ministre pour
la confiance qu'ils m'accordent alors
oui je suis fière et heureuse de
rejoindre le ministère du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion un ministère
du dialogue alors vos questions portent
sur la réforme des retraites et de
l'assurance chômage
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont exprimé leur
volonté de faire vivre la démocratie
sociale avec l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux
notre pays traverse une crise sans
précédent
précédent et ça ça n'est pas depuis
trois ans monsieur le député nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens veulent une
protection sociale à la hauteur des
enjeux du 21e siècle notre
responsabilité est donc d'ouvrir le
dialogue sur l'ensemble des sujets parce
que vous parlez de des retraites
monsieur le député est ce que notre
système de retraite est juste
non non et vous le savez il est injuste
pour les femmes dont les pensions sont
inférieures de 40% à celle des hommes
il est injuste pour nos concitoyens les
plus fragiles
il n'est plus adapté à la réalité des
parcours professionnels
est ce que notre système d'assurance
chômage a permis de ramener les chômeurs
vers l'emploi
non et vous le savez voilà pourquoi nous
devons en responsabilité engager une
concertation pour plus de justice
sociale avec l'ensemble des acteurs
seraient donc aux côtés du premier min
pour engager ce dialogue des deux
manches au magazine
la parole est à monsieur stéphane mazars
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre mes premiers mots
seront pour vous féliciter
suite à votre nomination aux fonctions
de garde des sceaux et permettez moi au
nom du groupe la république en marche de
vous adresser tous nos voeux de réussite
à la tête de ce grand ministère régalien
permettez moi permettez moi aussi de
saluer votre prédécesseur
madame nicole belloubet qui a été une
grande ministre de la justice
celle ci au cours des trois dernières
années a porté des textes importants
dans cet hémicycle et elle a toujours
fait preuve vis-à-vis des députés de
tous les bancs d'un profond respect
monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous connaissez la justice à travers de
la noble mission qui est celle de la
défense mais c'est désormais dans toutes
ses dimensions que vous allez devoir
l'appréhender de la cour d'assises au
tribunal paritaire des baux ruraux en
passant par le conseil de prud'hommes le
tribunal de commerce le tribunal
judiciaire ou encore le point d'accès au
droit de la profession d'avocat et des
autres professions réglementées hauts
fonctionnaires ou agents de l'état qui
soit magistrats greffiers surveillants
pénitentiaires ou encore agent de
probation ainsi monsieur le ministre ce
sont de très nombreux lieux d'exercice
du droit et d'innombrables acteurs à son
service qui sont désormais sous votre
responsabilité ou sur votre autorité et
ceci vous le savez attendent parfois des
moyens supplémentaires parfois de
nouvelles réformes parfois simplement
une reconnaissance pour leur permettre
de poursuivre l'exercice de leur mission
exigeante est essentiel dans un état de
droit
monsieur le ministre lors de votre
passion de pouvoir hier à la
chancellerie vous avez d'ores et déjà
énuméré quelques grands chantiers que
vous souhaitez ouvrir remise à plat de
l'ordonnancé 58 l'ordonance de 45
travail sur la présomption d'innocence
est le secret de l enquête le parquet
européenne monsieur le ministre
avec un tel programme quelles seront vos
priorités et quel sera votre méthode
pour permettre à la justice d'être une
administration à caen
davantage à la hauteur de cette vertu si
attendu par nos concitoyens
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice monsieur
le président monsieur le député mazars
merci d'abord pour vos gentils moore je
voudrais dire à tous les parlementaires
que je mesure l'ampleur de la tâche et
que je n'embrasse avec beaucoup
d'humilité
cette tâche à venir je voudrais
également vous dire ma fierté d'être ici
devant la représentation nationale
les priorités sont celles la réponse est
un peu dans la question pardonnez-moi
sont celles que j'ai évoquées hier nous
voulons une justice de proximité
ça a un sens il ya d'ores et déjà un
certain nombre de pistes je les ai
évoqué l' enquête préliminaire
sa durée la présomption d'innocence
les violations du secret de l'enquêté
ma méthode
monsieur le député puisque vous me posez
la question elle est très simple nous
avons connu vous et moi et parfois
ensemble d'ailleurs les mêmes enceinte
nous sommes des amoureux du
contradictoire moi j'ai besoin de vous
dans mes nouvelles fonctions
j'ai besoin de vous à la fois pour me
guider et aussi pour la contradiction
que vous apporterait rien n'est plus
important que le contradictoire qu'il
s'agisse d'une décision de justice ou
d'une décision ou d'une décision
politique
voilà ce que quelle sera ma méthode
auprès des magistrats de l'ensemble des
personnels de mon administration de tous
ceux qui voudront me rencontrer ma porte
est ouverte
vous n'aurez pas à la force et que ce
soit les parlementaires de la majorité
comme ceux de l'opposition
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure dans l'
affaire d'outreau les politiques de
toutes sensibilité
sont parvenus à trouver un ensemble de
décisions dans le monde et dans ma
mémoire 82 propositions c'est donc qu'il
est possible de faire cela et c'est ce
que je ferai merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur jean marie
sermier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
personne ne nie la réalité du
réchauffement climatique
il s'impose à nous pas demain
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs par exemple
le savent bien
les gelées de printemps du au démarrage
précoce de la végétation les épisodes de
canicules les périodes de sécheresse
abîme chaque année davantage des
récoltes en montagne on constate une
baisse de l'enneigement dans les forêts
ce sont les scolytes profitant de la
hausse des températures qui ravage les
massifs d'épicés à ces constats partagés
nous oblige tous nous oblige à refuser
les idéologies nous oblige à agir pour
l'environnement avec pragmatisme et avec
ambition dans le domaine par exemple de
l'énergie on a trop entendu le discours
anti nucléaire alors que le nucléaire
est une énergie décarbonée pilotable
soyons cohérents
défendons le maintien du parc existant
et investissons sur de nouvelles
générations de ppr pour réduire notre
empreinte carbone dans le domaine du
logement
on a trop confondues politiques sociales
et politiques environnementales soyons
ambitieux investissons massivement dans
l'isolation de nos bâtiments dans le
domaine du transport
certains nouveaux maires veulent parquet
les voitures aux portes des grandes
villes le problème ça n'est pas la
voiture
le problème c'est la pollution engageons
un plan ambitieux de développement des
véhicules propres en particulier à
l'hydrogène développons le ferroviaire
réhabilitant les petites lignes mais
aussi le tunnel lyon-turin développons
le fluvial et notamment le canal seine
nord europe
ces orientations devraient dépasser les
clivages pumin politique
hélas ce ne sont pas celle tracée par
eux madame la ministre de la transition
écologique hier votre priorité est de
concrétiser les engagements de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
constitue trop souvent un catalogue de
taxes de
holmes et d'interdictions nous ne
voulons pas d'une écologie punitive qui
opposerait la planète à l'humain celle
qui au fond on veut la décroissance
monsieur le premier ministre pensez vous
comme nous que la france doit concilier
la croissance et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
la parole est à madame barbara pour
piler ministre de la transition
écologique
merci merci monsieur le président cher
jean marie sermier un plaisir de vous
retrouver toujours aussi en verve et
quelque part un peu triste de vous
quitter parce que nous avons fait un bon
travail ensemble au sein de la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons eu des
des grands débats et vous en avez cité
certains mais sur tous ces sujets sur
tous ces sujets je continuerai à faire
comme je lé fais auparavant on va
travailler ensemble on va essayer de se
mettre autour de la table et on va
trouver les solutions ensemble avec vous
évidemment à l'assemblée nationale
et ça va arriver très vite avec les
citoyens de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat qui ne s'intéressaient pas ces
questions au départ et quand ils se sont
jetés dans le sujet ils ont compris
l'enjeu et ils nous ont fait des bonnes
propositions avec les territoires en
lien avec jacqueline gourault évidemment
parce que on ne peut pas réussir la
transition écologique
si on ne la fait pas sur les territoires
dont convainc réunir évidemment l'airé
les élus locaux pour pouvoir travailler
sur la question des énergies vous savez
la feuille de route est claire et vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour faire en
sorte qu'elle soit appliquée parce qu'on
a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui monsieur le
député monsieur à barbe
on a un vrai sujet sur le fait que nous
votons des lois et qu'elle ne sont pas
appliquées et vous pouvez compter sur
moi pour faire appliquer les lois pour
faire appliquer les stratégies qui ont
été votées par notre représentation
nationale
j'y tiens énormément et je m'y
emploierai vous avez oublié de sujets de
l'économie circulaire sur laquelle je
salue le travail de brune poirson qui a
vraiment fait un bon boulot sur le sujet
et que nous allons également continuer
voilà les enjeux sont là la relance
l'application de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat le travail sur les
territoires du concret c'est sûr ça
qu'on va bosser
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur yannick
favennec becker
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de la culture cher roselyne
bachelot que je suis heureux de
retrouver dans cet hémicycle
vous le savez les artistes sont
indispensables au lien social à
l'ouverture et à l'aide pas doucement de
notre société
ils sont les acteurs majeurs du
développement et de l'attractivité des
territoires comme celui que nous avons
en partage madame la ministre
les pays de la loire une terre de
festivals la politique culturelle de
notre pays dans sa globalité doit faire
face à de grands chantiers mais mais
comme vous l'avez dit lundi l'urgence
absolue en ce début d'été sera notamment
d'aidé à la remise en route des
festivals
vous annoncez des états généraux des
festivals mais ils ne sont qu'une
solution à moyen terme
or aujourd'hui il y a urgence les
annulations le festival sont dramatiques
tant pour les artistes les compagnies
que pour les très nombreux bénévoles qui
est des portes ou les territoires qui
les soutiennent et les accueille et j'ai
une pensée toute particulière pour les
festivals annulés dans mon département
de la mayenne au plan national 4000
manifestations ont été annulées entre
avril et août
le coût de ces annulations approcherait
les deux milliards 6,2 euros avec des
conséquences majeures en termes d'emploi
et d'économie des territoires la
création d'un fonds de 10 millions
d'euros annoncé par le ministère de la
culture pour faire face à ce séisme
n'est malheureusement pas à la hauteur
madame la ministre notre pays dans une
particulière vulnérabilité culturelle
des femmes des hommes des territoires
sont dans l attente d'une réponse
appropriée du gouvernement s'ils
n'attendent pas tout de l'état il on se
pose cependant besoin d'être soutenus ma
question est simple vous qui êtes là
ministre des artistes et des territoires
quelle réponse d'urgence à la hauteur
des enjeux
entendez vous apporter l écosystème du
spectacle vivant
en prenant en compte l'importance de nos
festivals
merci madame la ministre merci chers
collègues
la parole est à madame roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture
[Musique]
monsieur
monsieur le président
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les députés à
monsieur le député cheikh yannick
favenec bécaud vous avez rappelé notre
amour pour notre cher mayenne et qui a
été durement éprouvée par la suppression
d'un certain nombre de festivals je
pense au foin de la rue qui développe la
musique en ruralité
je pense aux 3 éléphants rien à voir
avec la politique un qui promeut des
musiques actuelles où je pense aussi aux
nuits de la mayenne qui développe le
théâtre classique et tous ces festivals
ont été soit annulés soit reporté le
gouvernement n'est pas resté inactif
dans ce domaine et je veux rappeler
l'action de franck riester qui est là
que je salue qu'avec détermination à
aider ce secteur qui a bénéficié bien
sûr et qui continue à bénéficier de
toutes les mesures générales
l'activité partielle et prêts garantis
par l'état le fonds de solidarité ainsi
que des mesures spécifiques
on peut penser au fonds d'urgence pour
le spectacle vivant dont ont bénéficié
les festivals au total ces cinq
milliards d'euros qui sont déjà
mobilisés bien entendu nous allons
continuer nous allons continuer à
travers le troisième projet de finance
de loi de finances rectificative et pour
le secteur culturel
c'est 1,06 milliard d'euros qui seront
mobilisés des dépenses fiscales des
exonérations sociales et bien sûr des
crédits budgétaires
et puis également dans cette loi de
finances rectificative
ce qui a été voulu par le président de
la république et qui sera très utile
pour nos festivals c'est à dire le
prolongement de cette année blanche pour
proroger le droit de l'intermittence cc
près d'un milliard d'euros ses 950
millions d'euros qui seront mobilisés
alors bien sûr vous avez 10
cette mesure d'urgence des 10 millions
d'euros qui seront utilisés pour nos
festivals c'est quand même des mesures
d'urgence et puis aussi d'adapter à la
crise sanitaire des festivals qui
pourraient reprendre
nous allons bien sûr continuer et ses
dispositions que vous attendez seront au
coeur du plan de relance le plan de
relance c'est la culture
la volonté du président de la république
merci la parole est à monsieur mots et
taïbo personnes monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs du gouvernement
chers collègues yolan d'abord je crois
qu'on peut être de l'opposition et
souhaité malgré tout la bienvenue et bon
courage au nouveau gouvernement
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre et outre-mer rien ne sera plus
jamais comme avant
on l'a entendu ce slogan au niveau local
comme au niveau national avant la crise
qu'ovide 15% des polynésiens était
considérée chômeurs soit seize mille
deux cents personnes auxquelles
l'honnêteté intellectuelle commandes
ajouté vingt-trois mille deux cents
individus que les statistiques ne classe
pas étrangement comme étant en recherche
d'emploi la réalité preco vide nous
placent donc déjà au delà des 40 % de
sans emploi avec la fermeture des
frontières et l'arrêt des dessertes
aériennes régulières décision de l'état
mais aussi des principales sources de
touristes comme les états unis
ces 22 % du pib polynésiens qui est en
danger de disparaître d'ici la fin de
l'année ce sont quinze mille chômeurs de
plus qui sont attendus dont 11000 dans
le seul secteur du tourisme procréatif
de l'état facteurs exogènes
internationaux limite du statut cette
crise a également rappelé de manière
douloureuse une réalité post coloniale
qui s'applique à tous les outre-mer la
dépendance de nos économie de comptoir
et la perte de notre souveraineté
alimentaire 88 % de ce qui est consommé
en polynésie où pourtant tout pousse est
importé allons-nous attendre le jour où
des carbo ne viendront plus à croze une
nouvelle crise sanitaire politico
économique pour nous saisir de cette
réalité monsieur ninis la polynésie
attend au delà des ping pong statutaire
de savoir si l'état va assumer ses
responsabilités autres maires non pas
pour retrouver la situation en t mais
pour construire ce fameux monde après
les solutions existent elles ont pour
nom permaculture apiculture circuit qu à
quoi peut ni jardins partagés pêche
responsable énergies propres et
renouvelables
certainement pas une énième version
bétonné tropicalisé du plan marshall ma
question est simple
êtes vous prêt à lancer avec les
responsables locaux un véritable plan de
transformation d outre-mer
faire plus de résilience et moins de
dépendance citant pierre rabhi un plan
colibri où chacun aura un rôle à jouer
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur sébastien lecornu ministre d
outre mer merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député pro terson merci pour vos
félicitations républicaines dans ce que
vous avez indiquée il ya semble-t-il
trois priorités qui déjà se se distingue
dans la continuité de l'action de la
ministre
girardin la première des choses est
singulièrement en polynésie française
c'est la stabilité institutionnelle lax
est un pays et les communes qu'il faut
saluer ici dans le rôle très
opérationnelle qui a été jouée sur ce
terrain et dans la gestion de la crise a
permis justement de réussir la période
de confinement les mesures de mise en
protection des populations et donc il
faut le dire en polynésie française
les choses ont été tenus grâce à cette
stabilité institutionnelle la deuxième
des choses ce sont les mesures d'urgence
pour la protection de l'emploi les
mesures sociales
je ne reste pas ici mais enfin on agit
sur le secteur bancaire on agit
évidemment sur des avances de trésorerie
pour le pays je sais que la députée
votre collègue député maina sage a
déposé des amendements en la matière
c'est l'accompagnement évidemment de
l'économie puis vous l'avez dit des deux
compagnies aériennes qui connaissent
difficultés importantes sur le cas de
l'état va se mobiliser
la troisième des choses c'est évidemment
imaginer une relance qui tient compte
des spécificités des différents
territoires d'outre-mer est là où je
vous rejoins dans la tonalité de votre
question c'est que quelque chose décidé
depuis paris de manière autoritaire ou à
la vague ne pourra pas fonctionner donc
il faut qu'on soit capable de décliner
le plan de relance sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
de manière spécifique sur les différents
territoires d'outre-mer et dans la
prolongation ce qui a été dit par la
ministre pompili il est évident que la
question de la transition écologique
d'occuper une part fondamentale de cette
relance tantale est d'ailleurs un des
éléments de l'identité de l'attractivité
touristique de la polynésie française il
ya un enjeu et olivier ferrand le sait
sur la santé sur lequel je sais que vous
nous attendait sur la signature d'une
convention santé avec le miz la sûreté
des solidarités on va s'y employer
et puis bien sûr traiter l'ensemble des
sujets liés à l'éloignement avec ses
sujets d'autosuffisance vous avez parlé
de des questions alimentaires mais pas
que la question de l'énergie me
semble-t-il au site une question
importante notamment d'un certain nombre
d'atomes
en tout cas nous serons aux côtés des
îles de la polynésie française pour le
faire monsieur le député merci monsieur
le ministre à paroles de saunhac remy
président madame la ministre délégué à
l'industrie mes chers collègues
la france est un pays de tradition un
pays de terroir un pays de savoir faire
est un pays de compétences depuis 40 ans
notre déficit commercial n'a cessé de se
creuser le poids de l'industrie dans le
pib ne cessé de décroître avec les
mesures engagées par la nouvelle
majorité nous pouvons noter une nette
amélioration depuis 2010 est visible par
une augmentation de la création
d'emplois industriels dans les
territoires et les chiffres le prouvent
le coc vide 19 a révélé des
problématiques d'approvisionnement et la
crise économique qui s'annonce risque
d'entraîner les déclins de nos champions
nationaux laissé entendre le rachat par
des puissances étrangères des biens et
des connaissances est essentielle à
notre pays notre souveraineté économique
est essentielle à la survie de notre
démocratie
et cette politique ne peut se mener sans
coordination avec les administrations de
l'état
la défense la sécurité intérieure et les
centres de recherche ainsi que les
institutions internationales l'union
européenne l'om c'est le cd eux le fmi
et j'en passe cette coordination est
nécessaire afin d'accompagner le retour
de ces industries françaises sur le sol
français tout en veillant à ne pas
déséquilibrer les pays en voie de
développement comme l'a rappelé le
président de la république et le premier
ministre le gouvernement constitué
récemment est un gouvernement de combat
vous avez accompli des missions
essentielles madame la ministre avant et
pendant la crise ces missions sont
aujourd'hui d'autre nature puisqu'il
s'agit aujourd'hui de réarmer la france
économiquement dans les secteurs
essentiels à la survie de notre pays et
accompagner le souhait des français afin
de produire au plus près du consommateur
ou pouviez vous nous dire quelques mots
madame
madame la ministre sur cette nouvelle
orientation merci merci chers collègues
la parole à madame agnès pannier winch
et ministre de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
crimi merci de rappeler d'abord le bon
bilan de ce gouvernement en matière
industrielle a effectivement nous vivons
une ère différente aujourd'hui mais ma
conviction c'est que le ministère de
l'industrie
ça ne doit pas être le ministère des
problèmes mais le ministère des
solutions et notre stratégie
elle s'articule autour de quatre axes le
premier axe c'est que notre industrie
soit un pilier de notre puissance
économique
c'est tout l'enjeu de la politique de
relocalisation qui sera ni simple ni
rapide mais que nous avons d'ores et
déjà engagé et qui doit être pensée non
seulement en paix au niveau de la france
mais également au niveau de l'europe
et vous savez les engagements qu'a pris
la commission européenne et le mouvement
extraordinaire qu'a fait l'allemagne
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république et du ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la relance pour
soutenir l'industrie européenne
notre deuxième axe c'est d'apporter des
solutions à la décarbonation de nos
activités parce que l'industrie elle la
doit décarbonés ses propres processus
mais surtout c'est elle qui va permettre
de trouver la façon de décarbonés la
mobilité décarbonée la construction de
logements et de tertiaire et donc c'est
tous ces leviers que nous devons
accompagner vous connaissez notre
investissement par exemple dans les
projets hydrogène que nous allons
poursuivre nous devons aller plus loin
plus fort plus vite en lien avec la
ministre des transitions écologique
le troisième axe c'est d'être plus agile
plus agile parce que nous devons faire
l'industrie du futur lusine du futur
c'est une transformation impérieuse si
nous voulons rester dans la course
industrielle enfin le quatrième axe etc
l'industrie elle doit être inclusive
c'est un projet de société vous
connaissez mon engagement pour les
femmes
nous devons l'ouvrir pour les jeunes
également pensé aux 100 diplômés aux
carrières qu'ils peuvent mener dans
l'industrie ou les rudes mais nous
l'avons warhol est à vendre
basile deux ponots monsieur le premier
ministre
quatre ministres de l'ecologie en trois
ans pour un bilan ridicule face à
l'enjeu de notre siècle
pas de tournant vers ni sociale ni rien
du tout ce nouveau gouvernement ne veut
rien dire
macro un jour macron toujours voici
votre seul mot d'ordre voit que ce qui
est accepté de ne rien dire de votre
politique générale avant que le monarque
de de l'elysée d'anne parlé nous
apprenons qu'un commissaire au plan
devrait être nommé depuis que le temps
que nous insistons sur la nécessité de
la planification nous ne pouvons que
nous réjouir de cette victoire
idéologique mais pour planifier quoi
pour planifier la destruction du rail
j'étais à perpignan ce lundi pour
défendre le dernier train de primeurs de
france
les cheminots ne décolère pas sa
suppression est le symbole du fiasco de
la politique anti écologique des manuels
macron vous aviez promis son maintien
vous avez menti
résultat 25 mille camions en plus sur
les routes par an et des emplois
nécessaires détruit pour planifier quoi
pour planifier le démantèlement de
l'état
vous avez choisi pour ministre du
travail celle qui a réduit de 10% le
nombre d'agents aux services du
ministère de la transition écologique
pour planifier la poursuite du
glyphosate vous aviez promis de
l'interdire en 2021
il nous empoisonnent rats jusqu'en 2027
au moins pour planifier la
délocalisation à tout va sur l'accord de
libre échange avec le mercosur
là encore flagrant délit de mensonge les
négociations ont continué et devrait
aboutir à l'automne pour planifier un
horizon vite de travailler plus pour
produire plus la misère progresse mais
vous subventionnez à coups de milliards
d'argent public
la distribution de dividendes aux
actionnaires et des licenciements par
milliers pour planifier la répression
des lanceurs d'alerté décrocheurs de
portraits des militants antinucléaires
de bure
notre planification de la bifurcation
écologique et solidaire est une méthode
mais surtout un contenu au service de
l'intérêt général humain la seule
planification qui vaille doit permettre
à chacun de subvenir à ses besoins
essentiels dans le respect des limites
alors monsieur le premier ministre votre
planification sera telle autre chose
qu'un combat contre le peuple
merci d'un panneau la parole et à madame
barbara pour piler ministre de la
transition écologique
merci monsieur le président madame
madame panneaux on se connaît bien on a
travaillé ensemble aussi au sein de la
commission développement durable et gens
vraiment hommage à tous mes collègues de
cette commission qui vont beaucoup me
manquer vous dit beaucoup de choses mais
ce que j'aimerais c'est que on essaye si
on veut avancer ensemble pour l'écologie
on a notre sensibilité vous en avez eu
une vous le savez j'en ai une et vous le
savez si on veut avancer ensemble
il faut qu'on essaye de sortir des
postures et il faut qu'on essaye de
regarder les choses froidement il y a eu
vous n'avez pas parlé du tout de ce qui
a été fait déjà vous n'avez pas parlé du
tout de ce qui a été fait la loi
mobilité la loi sur le climat de ce qui
a été fait également sur l'économie
circulaire de ski à et pourtant on ya
participé ensemble de ce qui a été fait
pour la transition énergétique et je
peux vous dire que je vais continuer
donc essayons de voir les choses et de
voir là où on nous devons effectivement
nous améliorer nous avons un rapport du
haut conseil pour le climat qui est
sorti ce matin
et évidemment nous nous entretiendrons
avec eux qui nous dit qu'il faut
accélérer sa tombe bien je l'avais dit
aussi et ça tombe bien le gouvernement
le premier ministre le président de la
république le disent aussi donc
travaillons plutôt ensemble pour y
arriver on va avoir des chantiers sur le
plan de relance sur la manière
d'impliquer tout le monde sur la
stratégie nationale bas carbone mais
aussi sur la loi qui va arriver sur
l'application de ce qui a été préservé
pour la danse qui a été proposée sur la
convention citoyenne sur le climat parce
que nous on doit faire ce que les
collectivités doivent faire ce que les
entreprises doivent faire beau son
ensemble là dessus s'il vous plaît on
est attendu sur des résultats et mais ce
que l'on soit dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition
ces résultats ils seront au service de
nos concitoyens et de nos enfants et
dont travaillons ensemble pour y arriver
je suis une mère de famille je peux vous
dire que ça m'intéresse d'apporter un
monde meilleur
à ceux qui nous suivent merci madame la
ministre la parole et à monsieur bruno
fuchs monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'inquiétude est extrême sur la
situation du député malien soumaïla
cissé arrivé second aux dernières
élections présidentielles soumaïla cisse
y représente la voie principale de
l'opposition démocratique au mali
ils étaient capturés dans une embuscade
le 25 mars dernier nous sommes sans
nouvelles depuis
mes chers collègues je veux lancer ici
en notre nom et un appel solennel à la
libération immédiate du député soumaïla
cissé je formule également le souhait
que la france us de toute son influence
pour qu'il puisse poursuivre son
engagement politique le plus rapidement
possible monsieur le ministre rassure et
nous rassurer sa famille et ses proches
donnez-nous enfin de bonnes nouvelles
par ailleurs ce rapt nous rappelle
l'importance majeure de l'action de la
france au sahel
ils nous renvoient également aux enjeux
qui touchent à la stabilité et à la
gouvernance de nombreux pays de l'espace
francophone en guinée conakry par
exemple alpha condé réfugié de longue
date et de longues années en france veut
comme d'autres avant lui changer la
constitution pour l'autoriser à un
troisième mandat
mes chers collègues et vous surprendre
mais par un tour de passe-passe la
constitution ratifier par référendum
n'est pas celle qui a été publiée
officiellement
et je m'étends pas ici sur les
répressions meurtrières aveugle contre
les civils au gabon le sort réservé au
principal leader d'opposition jean ping
assigne à résidence doit nous alerter
dans le même temps le chef de l'état
n'est plus en capacité de présider son
pays depuis 18 mois en raison de son
état de santé
le gabon et la guinée mais aussi le
cameroun le bénin à la guinée-bissau et
d'autres ont tous adhéré à la charte de
la francophonie et ont signé les accords
de cotonou et notamment son article 9
ils sont loin aujourd'hui d'honorer leur
signature
monsieur le ministre le président de la
république parle d'un nouveau chemin
pour les deux prochaines années à venir
comment la diplomatie française
va-t-elle dessiner un nouveau chemin
dans ses relations avec l'afrique
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et les affaires étrangères
monsieur le monsieur merci monsieur le
député bruno fuchs la france avec vous
mais ici dans cet hémicycle dit son
indignation devant la situation faite à
monsieur soumaïla cissé ces deux leaders
de l'opposition
il a été candidat aux élections
présidentielles il devront lui pris en
otage depuis trois mois et nous appelons
fortement à sa libération
nous appelons ceux qui l'enferment
aujourd'hui à le mettre à la disposition
de la démocratie malienne
par ailleurs vous avez évoqué la
situation au mali c'est vrai qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une période de tensions
sociopolitiques due à un arrêt de la
cour constitutionnelle à la suite des
élections législatives du mois d'avril
qui rend la situation extrêmement tendue
et les présidents des états du sahel ont
exprimé dans le cadre de la cedeao la
conférence économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest
un certain nombre de propositions visant
à atténuer la crise et à faire en sorte
que le climat politique s'apaise
nous souhaitons que ces dispositions
initié par la communauté économique des
états d'afrique de l'ouest puissent être
mises en oeuvre par les autorités
maliennes actuelle et plus largement
monsieur le député en afrique et vous le
savez bien y compris dans les pays en
difficultés que vous avez évoqué notre
posture et de re soutenir et la
démocratie et le droit la démocratie
dans les états fragiles
vous avez cité la guinée nous souhaitons
que les initiatives soient prises par le
président condé pour apaiser la
situation
à la suite d'un référendum que nous
avons contesté mais c'est vrai aussi
dans les états en crise ou en
particulier au sahel mais aussi au
cameroun il ya des exactions qui sont
commises que nous n'acceptons pas nous
leur disons en permanence aux différents
chefs d'état
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur patrick gazelle merci
beaucoup monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
alors que la france n'est pas encore
sortie de la crise du couronne un virus
que tout le monde est d'accord pour
souhaiter un monde d'après différents du
monde d'avant on pourrait penser que la
reconstruction économique écologique et
solidaire annoncé officiellement par le
président de la république se traduirait
par de premières mesures destinées à
corriger ce qui semblait le plus évident
chacun aurait pu penser que les premiers
enseignements tirer de cette crise
serait bien évidemment prise en compte
et que la relance économique
l'amélioration de notre système de
chanter et la préservation de
l'environnement seraient les priorités
de votre nouveau gouvernement monsieur
le premier ministre
or le nouveau calendrier parlementaire
que vous venez de nous proposer révèle
que pour vous la priorité c'est le vote
en urgence et en catimini de la seconde
lecture du projet de loi bioéthique et
je tiens à insister le tout en
supprimant le vote solennel
initialement prévu on peut et on doit
tout d'abord s'interroger sur
l'opportunité de cette seconde lecture
dans l'hémicycle dans une telle
précipitation et ceci durant la session
extraordinaire
alors que la période estivale débute que
le pays vit sous l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qu'est le conditions ne sont
pas remplies pour un et un débat serein
et apaisé en cette période estivale
il serait pertinent de débattre de cette
question qui en appelle à l'intime et à
chacun d'entre nous ultérieurement
c'est d'autant plus légitime qu'en
septembre le sénat ne siègera pas et
qu'il n'y a donc aucune urgence à
vouloir passer un tel texte au forceps
en expédiant le débat cela ne serait
absolument pas respectueux ni de notre
assemblée ni nos concitoyens monsieur le
premier ministre dans un souci
d'apaisement de concorde et de l'union
nationale et conformément à vos propres
déclarations depuis votre nomination
accepteriez vous monsieur le premier
ministre d'aller dans ce sens afin
d'être effectivement un accord avec vos
propres déclarations
je vous remercie
la parole merci chers collègues la
parole à monsieur olivier ans ministre
des solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député patrick hetzel appeler un chat un
chat dit que vous êtes contre la
possibilité que nous voulons donner aux
couples de femmes aux femmes seules de
boivin des enfants et une famille
utiliser des arguments de fond monsieur
les ailes mais utiliser des arguments de
fond vous n'êtes plus crédible sur le
fond que sur la forme pourquoi monsieur
est elle là bas parce que ce texte il ya
déjà plus d'un an
c'est en catimini un peu long un an déjà
démarche parlementaire
ensuite parce que ce n'est que la
deuxième fois l'année dernière lecture
est fait ensuite parce que la commission
spéciale de bioéthique a fait un
formidable travail et qu'elle a adoptées
sans coup férir le texte dans les délais
qui étaient impartis et parce qu'il ya
des attentes sociétales qui sont
nombreuses messieurs les députés je
demanderai un minima de remettre votre
masque quand vous criez penser votre
groupe ne criait pas un cluster dans
l'assemblée nationale
montrez l'exemple montre l'exemple sur
le président jeudi est donc ce n'est pas
une loi adoptée en catimini
on est déjà un an de démarches des
parlementaires de tous bords ont
travaillé il ya d'ailleurs des questions
consensuel qui peuvent transcender les
clivages politiques
ce sont des avancées sociales de la
beauce et sociétales sont importantes
qui font également je vais baisser d'un
volume vous battre et peut-être le vôtre
ce sont les avants c'est également
important pour la médecine pour la
recherche dans notre pays ce sont des
rechutes des zones et qui sont
importantes pour les enfants qui sont en
recherche de filiation ce sont des
questions qui sont importantes mais si
mais si pour combattre de nouvelles
maladies et puis pour ses belles
avancées sociétales que moi titre de
ministre des solidarités et la santé je
prône déjà depuis un certain nombre
d'années que je suis très fier que notre
gouvernement portent à savoir
l'autorisation de considérer l'évolution
des familles comme une évolution
sociétale saine sereine normal le débat
va suivre son cours et je l'espère le
plus tôt possible
merci monsieur willy la parole est à
monsieur frédéric descrozaille il
monsieur le président ma question
j'avais la parole leur collègue
merci le 7 mai la question s'adresse au
ministre
l'action et des comptes publics me
glisse dans le contexte que nous
connaissons
si l'état n'était pas intervenu notre
économie ce qu'un champ de ruines et
s'est reconnue par l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques le fait que l'action
de l'état a été efficace dans ce
contexte les urssaf accompagne les
entreprises leur propose des solutions
et plus particulièrement depuis la loi
que nous avons adoptée en août 2010 8
pour un état au service d'une société de
confiance et je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur un point particulier
certains chefs d'entreprise ont besoin
et sollicite les urssaf pour transiger
en fait sur des dispositions prévues
dans le projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale adoptée le 22 décembre
2014 selon des dispositions
réglementaires précisé dans un décret
paru le 15 février 2016 des transactions
donc par exemple pour des pénalités de
retard
or les urssaf sont obligés de leur
opposer une fin de non recevoir
navré parce que ce fameux décret du 15
février 2016 prévoit que ces
transactions
ces transactions doivent être conformes
à un modèle de protocole transactionnel
défini par arrêté ministériel
arrêté ministériel qui n'existent pas
parce qu'il n'est jamais paru donc
monsieur le ministre se dit en passant
que aucun agent de l'état ne se soit
sentie responsable du fait que la
volonté du législateur régulièrement
établis en 2014 n'est pas applicable en
2020 en raison d'une inconséquence
réglementaire voire administrative
ça laisse songeur pour le dire
aimablement donc ma question c'est
est-ce que vous nous confirmer que vous
allez prendre une disposition rapide
pour que cette situation soit
régularisée et que les chefs
d'entreprise puissent solliciter les
urssaf pour ses fameuses transaction
prévue depuis 2014 et surtout que les
dispositions que nous allons adopter
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative dans l'examen va
recommencer aujourd'hui même vont bien
être établi avec le même esprit de
service qui anime les urssaf
de la même manière partout sur le
territoire et pour tous les chefs
d'entreprise merci monsieur le député la
parole à monsieur olivier du soft
ministre chargé des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames
merci à tous
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député descrozaille à la
question précise réponse précise la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2015 prévoit effectivement la
possibilité pour les ursaff d'une
procédure transactionnel un décret a été
publié en février 2016 il manque un
arrêté avec le modèle de protocole
transactionnel
c'est un arrêté va être publié dans les
semaines qui viennent pour que cette
disposition puisse être mise en oeuvre
au delà de cette réponse précise
j'espère satisfaisante
votre question me permet de saluer le
travail des urssaf le travail des urssaf
depuis plusieurs mois est absolument
exceptionnelles pour accompagner les
entreprises en difficulté ce sont les
urssaf qui sur instruction de mon
prédécesseur le miz l'action et des
comptes publics ont mises en oeuvre le
report des échéances de cotisation pour
permettre aux entreprises de toutes
tailles de bénéficier d'une trésorerie
particulièrement préservé pendant toute
cette période de crise ce sont aussi les
urssaf qui vont mettre en oeuvre
l'article 18 du projet de loi de
finances rectificative que vous examine
actuellement cet article 18 voulu à la
fois par gérald darmanin et par bruno le
maire permet l'exonération des
cotisations sociales dans de conditions
particulières
d'abord pour les entreprises de moins de
dix salariés les tpe qui ont fait
l'objet d'une fermeture administrative
elles seront exonérées de cotisations
patronales pour trois mois et nous avons
prévu aussi de leur accorder un crédit
de cotisation qui leur permettra de
faire face aux échéances à venir et nous
allons élargir cette exonération de
cotisations aux entreprises de moins de
250 salariés des secteurs les plus
frappés par cette crise nous pensons
notamment au secteur des cafés hôtels
restaurants mais aussi aux entreprises
qui sont particulièrement lié à ces
entreprises qui ont subi une mise à zéro
parfois de leur chiffre d'affaires
pendant cette activité
la meilleure démonstration je crois de
l'implication à venir des urssaf pour
garantir la mise en oeuvre des
dispositions du plfr c'est ce que les
urssaf ont fait pendant les trois
derniers mois leur réactivité au service
des entreprises de france
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à monsieur jean paul dufrègne
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il ya quelques jours
l'assemblée nationale a adopté dans le
cadre de notre niche parlementaire ce
que tout le monde appelle depuis
plusieurs années la loi chassaigne même
si votre majorité en a réduit la portée
avec un système d'écrêtement et une mise
en application à compter du 1er janvier
les députés communistes et gdr se sont
réjouis de cette avancée pour près de
200 mille retraités agricoles dont le
minimum retraite ne pourra plus être
inférieure à 85 % du smic contre 75%
aujourd'hui lors de nos discussions il a
été adopté un amendement précisant que
la date d'entrée en vigueur pouvait être
avancées si les solutions techniques le
permettait la mutualité sociale agricole
dit aujourd'hui que rien ne s'oppose à
ce que ce dispositif soit appliqué dès
le 1er janvier 2021 l'entendez vous des
directives seront elles donner
rapidement ce sens pour autant le
problème des conjoints n'est pas réglée
et toutes ces femmes aux 12 heures de
travail par jour est dit sans profession
vont continuer de percevoir des
retraites entre 300 et 500 euros par
mois ce n'est plus tolérable
ces femmes de l'ombre participer aux
travaux agricoles élevés les volailles
faisait les fromages qu'elle vendait au
marché local en plus de tenir la maison
l'adoption de la proposition de loi
chassaigne a remis en lumière cette
situation pour les femmes de la
génération concernée
monsieur le premier ministre pendant
encore combien de temps celles qui ont
tant travaillé
oui tant travaillé pantel percevoir des
retraites de misère nous déposerons
prochainement une proposition de loi
pour y remédier merci chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député jean paul dufrègne je
le dire clairement il ne faut pas
attendre
on a beaucoup trop attendu depuis
beaucoup trop longtemps donc comme on
dit moi je remettrai pas à demain ce qui
peut être fait aujourd'hui
et ce qui est clair aussi c'est que vous
connaissez la mobilisation et je
voudrais vraiment rendre hommage à mon
prédécesseur didier guillaume la
mobilisation du ministre la mobilisation
de cette majorité
mais la mobilisation de beaucoup d'entre
vous pour en finir avec cette injustice
du niveau de rémunération des
agriculteurs des agricultrices pendant
leurs activités ou après à la retraite
et je salue la ppl du président
chassaigne bien connu ici
cette proposition de loi et qui a été
débattue c'est une véritable avancée
sociale vous l'avait dit et moi je
l'assumé clairement et j'en ferai un axe
de mon action le social dans
l'alignement de leurs grilles culture
c'est très important c'est très
important d'avoir une politique sociale
agricoles et une fois qu'on a dit ça
vous savez pourquoi l'amendement a été
portée c'est à dire une amie une mise en
application plus tard en 22 mai deux
pouvant être avancée dès lors que le
système d'information permettra
permettra de s'assurer que l'ensemble
des droits fait avec la msa soit assurée
dès lors que le système sera prêt moi je
m'y engage
on mettra en oeuvre je ne remettrai pas
à demain ce qui peut être fait
aujourd'hui
s'agissant de la retraite des
agricultrices là aussi il faut agir avec
méthode
c'est intolérable vous l'avais dit je
partage il ya une mission qui a été
confiée au député lionel causse et
nicolas turquois que je salue dont les
travaux doivent être remis à l'automne
pour pouvoir avancer notamment sur ce
sujet évidemment il faut que ce soit
fait dans la concertation mais
évidemment là aussi il faut avancer vite
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à mme albertine alesi me suis tu freines
pardon merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
pour positive est effectivement notre
proposition est tout à fait dans le
prolongement de notre ppn et les deux
questions vous l'avez souligné sont
étroitement liés vous avez activé
accepter la première eh bien je suis
certain que vous ne refusez pas sur la
liste
bonnaire monsieur le premier ministre à
la santé mentale ne peut plus être le
parent pauvre de la médecine
s'il est une chose que la crise
sanitaire nous est démontrée c'est la
grande fragilité d'un secteur qu'il est
urgent de réformer la détresse psychique
n'épargne personne
combien de patients de soignants
d'étudiants de parents et de personnes
isolées ont perdu pied pendant le
confinement mais aussi depuis le
déconfinement lépi phare a observé que
les anxiolytiques ont augmenté pendant
cette période de 290000 prescription de
même pour les hypnotiques avec 100000
prescription supplémentaires le nombre
de passages aux urgences home pour
motifs psychiatriques a quant à lui
triplé dès le début du déconfinement
qu'en est il des patients enfermé contre
leur gré au prétexte du confinement
sanitaire la contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté dans son
dernier avis s'est indigné des
conditions d'hospitalisation de certains
patients elle a relevé des atteintes
graves aux droits fondamentaux dans
plusieurs hôpitaux psychiatriques et a
déclaré que le secteur avait besoin
d'une nouvelle loi le conseil
constitutionnel saisi par une qpc a
répondu le 19 juin en demandant au
législateur que les pratiques
d'isolement et de contention puissent
être soumises au contrôle d'un juge
la loi doit changer et ce dès fin 2020
je rappelle que caroline fiat et moi
même avons fait état dans notre rapport
sur l'organisation de la santé mentale
de la situation très précaire de ce
secteur à bout de souffle
nous avions formulé des propositions
concrètes monsieur le premier ministre
ne vous trompez pas l'impact psychique
de cette crise sécuritaire mérite de
placer la santé mentale au centre des
préoccupations
c'est en effet un sujet majeur pour le
groupe écologie démocratie et c'est dans
la solidarité le ségur doit être plus
que de simples annonces budgétaires
c'est pourquoi je vous le demande êtes
vous prêt à accroître les financements
de la santé mentale et pouvez vous vous
engagez quant à la proposition d'une
nouvelle loi
je les accueille
monsieur olivier durand ministre des
solidarités et de la sorte et madame la
députée c'est vrai qu'il ya eu pendant
cette période de crise qu vide une
augmentation et on le comprend des
troubles anxieux parfois des troubles
dépressifs des familles qui ont été
confinés pendant des semaines chez elles
des personnes qui ont été éloignés de
leur emploi d'autres qui l'ont perdu cet
artisan qui ferme son commerce subit lui
aussi un stress très fort cet enfant qui
ne va pas à l'école et qui s'interrogent
pourquoi sur les pour les raisons pour
lesquelles il est éloigné ses copains
subit aussi un stress qui n'est pas legs
à négliger vous savez pendant toute la
période de crise qu vide et notamment
pendant la période de confinement nous
avons mis en place du soutien
psychologique pour toutes celles et ceux
qui en relever ou qu'ils voulaient en
émettre le souhait avec des appels
téléphoniques des numéros verts des
plateformes des associations des
psychiatres des psychologues
c'était indispensable il y avait eu
d'ailleurs un soutien psychologique
important mis en place à destination des
soignants qui eux mêmes ont été soumis à
un stress qui justifiait pleinement
qu'on les accompagne
et puis quels secteurs de psychiatrie et
des soins qu'ils soient en milieu ouvert
ou en milieu fermé ça a été très dur et
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion dans cet
hémicycle de saluer le travail
extraordinaire extraordinaire des
soignants en milieu psychiatrique parce
que c'était encore plus difficile
c'était encore plus difficile de gérer
les 14 n de gérer les mesures
d'isolement d'expliquer à des malades
qui parfois peut évidemment comprendre
et parfois ne peuvent pas appréhender ce
qui est en train de se passer notamment
des malades en situation de délire et
cet accompagnement du quotidien avec
l'éloignement plus et familles des
proches aidants était encore plus dur et
pourtant la psychiatrie est tenu
la psychiatrie est tenu j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer l'ensemble des
acteurs de la filière à plusieurs
reprises les saluts et de les remercier
et de tenir compte des organisations
qu'ils avaient su mettre en place de
manière à ce que nous puissions dans la
durée nous appuyer sur leur initiative
nous travaillons pour cela avec franck
bellivier professeur de psychiatrie et
qui est déléguée interministérielle et
puis maintenant madame la députée nous
avons un travail qui a commencé un
travail de résilience collective la
crise n'est pas derrière nous le gros
d'épidémie de cette vague épidémique est
derrière nous il nous faut nous
reconstruire individuellement
collectivement
dans notre vie du quotidien dans nos
familles de nos cercles amicaux et
professionnels
évidemment stationné pour le faire
biémouret merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'égalité femmes hommes de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances
madame la ministre vous êtes le nouveau
visage de l'égalité femmes hommes
votre parcours est un sans-faute modèle
d'un ascenseur social qui honore la
république dans ce qu'elle a de meilleur
vous portez désormais la parole et les
intérêts de l'ensemble des femmes de
notre pays
initialement ou peut-être encore grande
cause du quinquina quinquennat nous ne
savons plus pour autant qu'il soit
exemplaire et méritant le modèle ne fait
pas la politique
votre vision de la lutte pour l'égalité
nous sommes très libérale au regard des
déclarations que nous vous connaissons
or la sortie de la crise que nous venons
de traverser a démontré la réalité de la
condition de la majorité des femmes à
savoir être invisible sous payés et
surchargé la république c'est toujours
temps d'y apporter son soutien aux plus
fragiles et à leur permettre une
émancipation qui au passage ne passe pas
uniquement par le travail tel que le
prendre le gouvernement
c'est le cas pour toutes celles qui ont
été en première ligne
à l'occasion de la crise sanitaire le
haut conseil pour l'égalité femmes
hommes s'accordent à dire que le risque
est grand que les inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes s'accroissent
maintenant les femmes sont la voie de la
pauvreté et de la dépendance
nous nous nous interrogeons sur votre
vision du féminisme alors qu'en 2018
vous déclariez mon conseil serait de
prendre davantage de responsabilités
plus vous montez dans la hiérarchie -
vous êtes confrontés au sexisme au delà
de la discussion autour de la machine à
café est ce le message que vous
souhaitez porter si les superlatifs ne
manquent jamais à ce quinquennat
au delà de la coupe communication marque
de fabrique du président de la
république
allez-vous renouer le lien avec les
associations féministes et entamer un
travail collectif avait les moyens pour
lutter contre les violences faites aux
femmes
à la hauteur des enjeux merci merci
chers collègues la parole est à vous
laver les événements est nommée ministre
déléguée chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité et
de l'égalité des chances
bonjour à tous bon jour à tout c'est un
véritable honneur pour moi d'être avec
vous dans cette salle aujourd'hui j'ai
l'habitude de vous regarder à la
télévision et être ici avec vous ça me
paraît totalement surnaturel vous n'êtes
plus beau en vrai madame la députée
merci beaucoup pour votre question c'est
une question qui me touche
personnellement
pour plusieurs raisons comme vous le
savez tous je ne suis pas une femme
politique et je n'avais jamais envisagé
de rentrer dans la politique
jusqu'à ce que monsieur le premier
ministre m'expliquer pourquoi c'était le
moment de le faire et il y a des
engagements qui ne viennent pas du
cerveau mais qui viennent du coeur
inutile de vous dire que parce que je
suis une femme parce que je suis une
mère parce que j'ai grandi dans une cité
quand je vous dis que l'émancipation
économique est la base pour sortir de la
misère et de la pauvreté et pour être
considéré c'est une vérité
maintenant il y à un autre élément parce
que j'ai appris que je n'avais que deux
minutes il y à un autre élément que je
voudrais souligner et il a été évoqué
par une députée qui vient de m'envoyer
un message qui est pardon j'ai oublié
son nom mais elle me dit je suis dans
l'éducation
je ne serais pas ici devant vous
aujourd'hui si je n'avais pas eu la
chance d'avoir des enseignants qui m'ont
appris à parler à marcher à me déplacer
et à m'exprimer
alors oui l'émancipation économique est
fondamentale mais elle ne peut avoir
lieu que si tous les citoyens et
citoyennes sont formés qu'ils ont une
bonne éducation et qu'ils peuvent lever
la tête et avancer
[Musique]
et je terminerai en vous disant que je
n'aurais pas quitté mon emploi que je
n'aurais pas quitté l'afrique du sud où
mon mari et ma fille se trouvent encore
pour venir vous rejoindre aujourd'hui si
monsieur le premier ministre et madame
et monsieur le président de la
république c'est vraiment deux minutes
dans ce paisible alors j'ai terminé mon
kiff hauteur mais s'il n'avait pas
garanti que cette cause de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes restaient
et resterait encore une grande cause
duke energy madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur thierry benoit
merci mon cher président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre au nom des députés du groupe
u10 et indépendant je voudrais saluer
votre nomination ainsi que celle des
nouveaux membres du gouvernement de ce
gouvernement et dire ici que je souhaite
naturellement pour la france et les
français
la réussite de votre gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre je voudrais
aborder un point qui m'est chère qui me
tient à coeur mais ce stade un sujet
très sensible
c'est la question du cumul de
l'encadrement du cumul monsieur premier
ministre des rémunérations des fonctions
d'un certain nombre de hauts
fonctionnaires
nous avons travaillé dans cet hémicycle
dans notre pays
nous avons clarifié ce sujet du cumul
pour les élus locaux pour les
parlementaires et pour les ministres
tant en termes de fonctions qu'en termes
de rémunération sur le premier ministre
nous sommes en 2020 et les français
comme moi apprennent qu'un haut
fonctionnaire peut cumuler certaines
fonctions dans le cadre de son métier il
est délégué interministériel présidé une
agence de l'état
il peut aussi cumuler ses fonctions avec
des des mandats d'élus locaux
et lorsqu'au fait le cumul de la somme
des fonctions de la somme des
rémunérations et des indemnités
certains montants choquent un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes
ils ont été nombreux à nous le dire à
l'automne 2010 8 au mouvement au moment
des mouvements sociaux qui avait
concentré un certain nombre de français
sur les ronds points
monsieur le premier ministre je voudrais
vous interroger pour savoir si vous
inscrivez votre action dans la volonté
du président emmanuel macron et dans la
volonté traduite par edouard philippe
au début de cette législature d'apporter
de la clarification encadrement fonction
rémunérations indemnités pour un certain
nombre de hauts fonctionnaires je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à madame line
beauchamp la ministre de la
transformation de la fonction publique
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le député vous pouvez compter
sur l'engagement plein et entier de ce
gouvernement pour garantir l'exemplarité
et la transparence
votre ppl en janvier 2018 a permis au
gouvernement de prendre des engagements
ils ont été suivis par la publication
d'un décret vous le savez en février
dernier notamment un décret qui permet
pour les autorités administratives
indépendantes d'avoir une seule règle
pour fixer les rémunérations nous
avançons également sur la transparence
de la queue d'un rémunérations des hauts
fonctionnaires et vous pouvez compter
sur moi un point important à mes yeux
nous devons attirer les meilleurs nous
devons rendre notre action publique plus
proche plus efficace plus simple nous
devons évaluer ceux qui sont aux
commandes de l'action publique et tous
les agents doivent pouvoir non pas être
dans la suspicion mais être dans
l'action et donc compter sur ce
gouvernement si nous voulons les
résultats si nous voulons que sur tous
nos territoires les français est une
action publique à leur service si nous
voulons que les agents puissent être
soutenu leur combat quotidien de rendre
service et nous l'avons vu ils ont tenu
pendant la crise nous devons avoir avec
sa transparence avoir de la clarté avoir
des règles nous allons les clarifier si
besoin
mais comptez sur nous pour mener le bon
combat le bon combat s'est servi les
français c'est leur apporter là où ils
sont une action publique qui
correspondent à leurs besoins et leurs
attentes à la modernité du 21e siècle et
doute pouvons sur ces sujets ne prendre
aucun retard
je tiens ici et c'est le sujet que vous
abordez les hauts fonctionnaires notre
pays ont permis à l'état de tenir
nous devons les accompagner les évaluer
et c'est ainsi que nous travaillerons
par la confiance parce que les français
attendent des résultats et nous devons
toujours soutenir ceux qui leur
apportent
si madame la ministre la parole à
monsieur adrien cnas monsieur le premier
ministre c'est un parlement une nouvelle
fois abaissé qui se réunit aujourd'hui
mises à la disposition du gouvernement à
sa convenance
dans une séance de questions
exceptionnel et alors que votre discours
de politique générale n'aura lieu que la
semaine prochaine
par conséquent nous ne savons pas qui
dans cette assemblée vous accorde sa
confiance ou ne vous la corde pas mais
il est vrai que la cour n'a pas besoin
de vous entendre pour vous applaudir dès
lors que le monarque que vous a choisi
nous savons que parmi vos intentions
figure celle de remettre à l'ordre du
jour la réforme des retraites que 70%
des français rejeter et contre laquelle
nous avons mené une rude bataille
parlementaire soldée par un lamentable
49 3 soyez assuré monsieur le premier
ministre que vos intentions ne saurait
passer inaperçu et que nous sommes
disposés s'il le fallait à vous menez
une bataille plus rude encore que celle
que ce parlement a connu il y a quelques
mois
en effet nous avons eu l'occasion de
démontrer mille fois ici que derrière
les bonnes intentions affichées se casse
un projet qui ne vise qu à contraindre
les français à travailler toujours plus
longtemps pour atteindre le même niveau
de pension et quand cela il est
contraire aux engagements présidentiels
il prépare une rupture certaine avec le
modèle solidaire par répartition aux
bénéfices des assureurs et des banques
à l'heure où notre pays subit le choc
d'une récession brutale
certains doivent se faire tout petit sur
ses bancs qui nous expliquait qu'avec la
même proportion de richesse nationale
consacrée aux retraites
on pourrait servir toujours plus de
retraités par ailleurs monsieur le
premier ministre
alors que plus de 700 mille jeunes
entreront sur le marché du travail à la
rentrée
dans ce contexte de chômage accru
l'avenir n'est pas à travailler
davantage
mais bien à travailler moins pour
travailler mieux et travailler tous pour
obtenir le plein emploi
à mesure que la productivité a augmenté
ce combat est le fil rouge du mouvement
ouvrier dans l'histoire et nous n'y
renoncerons jamais monsieur le premier
ministre
alors que les syndicats vous disent non
et que l'opposition parlementaire vous
dis non
pourquoi vous entêter dans cette
déclaration de guerre sociale hop et r
si chers collègues la parole pas valable
avec bornes du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député quatre ans je connais
votre engagement sur les questions
sociales et pour ma part j'aurai à coeur
de travailler avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires comme des partenaires
sociaux pour apporter des réponses
concrètes à nos concitoyens
alors vous le savez notre pays traverse
une crise sans précédent et je pense que
cette situation inédite devrait nous
conduire à sortir des postures et des
caricatures parce que vous le savez
monsieur le député tout autant que vous
j'ai à coeur de conforter notre
protection sociale
et c'est pourquoi le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
exprimé leur volonté de s'appuyer sur
l'ensemble des acteurs de la démocratie
sociale pour surmonter la crise d'
aborder l'ensemble des sujets et de
bâtir un système de protection juste et
équitable adaptée aux enjeux du 21e
siècle
parce que ce système de retraite que
vous défendez avec tant de vigueur
monsieur le député est il juste il ne
l'est pas et vous le savez il est
injuste pour les plus fragiles de nos
concitoyens il est injuste pour les
femmes dont les pensions sont
inférieures de 40% à celle des hommes
il est plus adapté à la réalité des
parcours professionnels
voilà pourquoi nous devons en
responsabilité engager une concertation
pour plus de justice sociale avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et je serai donc
aux côtés du premier ministre pour
engager ce dialogue dès demain la tâche
devant nous est immense et les bases
sont solides
la méthode est posée la volonté est là
et je sais qu'elle est largement partagé
sur ses bancs merci madame la ministre
la parole est à madame géraldine banier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des solidarités et
de la santé monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais vous alerter sur la
situation extrêmement préoccupante dans
laquelle se trouve la pédopsychiatrie
dans le département de la mayenne avec
une succession de fermeture de centres
médico-psychologiques à château gontier
et renée évron faute de médecin à la fin
du confinement il a été annoncé que le
cmp de château gontier resterait fermée
provisoirement
il est proposé à 40 des 120 patients un
suivi à laval mais sept à trente
kilomètres et à 40 km de routes
si les cmp dernier et d'évron ont pu
partiellement rouvrir ils sont en
réalité en sursis de plus les cmp de
mayenne et laval sont également menacés
puisque des départs de médecins sont à
prévoir
les familles les élus s'inquiètent
logiquement pour la santé des enfants et
l'absence d'alternative de soins un
collectif s'est créé non seulement pour
soutenir les médecins mais aussi pour se
préoccuper de la réponse qui sera
apportée pour des enfants en grande
souffrance psychique le maintien d'un
service public de proximité et de
qualité est indispensable dans
l'ensemble des territoires
un enfant suivie depuis six ans au cmp
de château gontier nous le rappelle j'ai
des troubles autistiques
et quand je suis au cmp je réussis à me
calmer et puis il ya d'autres enfants
comme moi et même d'autres pour qui
aller au cmp est indispensable bref s'il
vous plaît ne fermait pas le cmp
monsieur le ministre
devant cette crise sans précédent dans
notre département dynamique dont la
qualité de vie n'est plus à démontrer on
l'a vu avec l'énumération des festivals
dans la mayenne de madame bachelot tout
à l'heure mais troisième désert médical
de france quelles réponses pouvez vous
apporter aux patients et à leurs
familles en attente de continuité des
soins
merci chers collègues l'apport la notion
olivier ferrand ministre des solidarités
de la santé madame la députée géraldine
banier au delà de la situation
particulière de la mayenne que vous dans
votre question vous faites en fait en
réalité état d'une situation
problématique dans notre pays tout
entier le problème c'est celui de
l'accès aux soins notamment en
pédopsychiatrie sur une partie
croissante du territoire national c'est
inacceptable
vous demandez si je compte fermer un cmp
je n'ai jamais eu l'ambition la vocation
la volonté l'idée saugrenue de fermer à
saint pée en revanche effectivement il
faut des médecins des soignants pour
ouvrir un centre médico psychologique
comme il en faut pour ouvrir des
hôpitaux
je veux que la france mette le paquet
pour la filière de pédopsychiatrie nous
ne pouvons pas rester les bras ballants
a constaté que des enfants qui trouent
qui souffrent de troubles doivent
attendre 18 mois pour avoir un
diagnostic doivent attendre des semaines
ou des mois pour pouvoir bénéficier de
soins spécialisés ou de rééducation
c'est un drame du quotidien pour les
enfants concernés
parents concernés pour les enseignants
concernés et je crois qu'un pays comme
la france devrait s'enorgueillir de
mettre encore une fois le paquet
l'accent et tous les moyens tous les
moyens je le dis avec sincérité mêmes
émotions pour pouvoir structurer une
filière digne de ce nom en matière de
santé mentale et d'accompagnement de
l'enfant nous pouvons envisager
différentes solutions madame la députée
je ne peux pas faire ici de propositions
qui ne serait ce qu il serait arbitre m
il ya des idées créé peut être
identifiée demain une filière spécifique
de pédopsychiatrie à côté de la filière
psychiatrique adulte je ne sais pas je
lui en parler avec les experts peut-être
rendre faciliter l'accès direct
psychologue sur prescription pour les
mineurs peut-être que la france est
capable de faire cela
aujourd'hui continue la situation et
pour vous répondre sur le cas précis du
cmp que vous citez je crois qu'il ya une
bonne piste
avec le recrutement d'un médecin en
provenance du chu d'angers qui viendrait
à partir de septembre
faire une vacation hebdomadaire au cmp
de château gontier ce serait un
doublement par rapport à l'existant et
puis il ya des postes partagés entre le
sésame et le ch laval pardon je dois ici
et lire mes fiches
je ne connais pas encore tous les
établissements de france en tout cas
madame la députée merci pour votre
sollicitation votre attention
des quelques 20 ans pas plus que
quelques secondes simplement pour faire
un appel aussi aux étudiants en médecine
il faut venir aussi dans nos territoires
qui ont besoin de médecins merci la
parole à madame josiane corps de l'eau
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
je souhaite vous alerter sur la
catastrophe économique et financière qui
risque de décimer une profession entière
si rien n'est fait en effet seuls les
discothèques font encore à ce jour
l'objet d'une fermeture administrative
contrairement aux cafés restaurants qui
ont pu reprendre leurs activités à
partir du 2 juin sous réserve d'observer
strictement des gestes barrières
j'ai reçu les gérants des discothèques
de ma circonscription qui m'indique une
réouverture le 21 septembre comme
semblent le prévoir le gouvernement
entraînera le dépôt de bilan de 90 % des
établissements installés en saône et
loire
à l'échelle du pays ce sont 1600
discothèque et 120 mille emplois directs
qui sont menacés si l'autorisation de
rouvrir ne leur est pas accordée dans
les plus brefs délais j'ai bien
conscience que le virus est toujours là
mais que constate-t-on
avec la fermeture prolongée des
discothèques le contraire de l'effet
recherché avec la tenue de fêtes
clandestines organisé à partir de sites
dédiés comme soirée privée sur le net ou
bien par le biais des réseaux sociaux
ce sont ainsi des milliers de jeunes qui
se réunissent lors de fêtes improvisées
dans lesquels aucune mesure de
protection sanitaire n'est respectée les
gérants de ces établissements sont des
professionnels responsables parfaitement
à même d'organiser des fêtes dans le
strict respect des gestes barrières
continuer de leur interdire de reprendre
leurs activités revient à les traiter en
coupable et a condamné la plupart
d'entre eux à disparaître du paysage
économique et de notre patrimoine
culturel populaire et festif c'est
pourquoi monsieur le ministre je vous
presse d'écouter l'appel au secours de
ces hommes et femmes qui ne méritent pas
l'ostracisme actuelle que leur oppose
deux gouvernements
aucune entreprise ne peut survivre à
sept mois de fermeture
il y a urgence monsieur le premier
ministre quelle solution allez vous
proposer un interminable mais plutôt la
chance de pouvoir retravailler clair ce
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame la députée josiane corneloup vous
venez de recevoir des applaudissements
fournis de tous les bancs de cette
assemblée nationale et pour cause la
seule
le seul élément j'enlèverai votre
question c'est le mot ostracisme de la
part du gouvernement
c'est inutile et c'est factuellement
faux vous avez raison madame la députée
de rappeler que les discothèques sont
fermées pour raisons sanitaires
elles ont été parfois ouvertes dans
certains pays parfois refermer la suisse
la semaine dernière a enregistré un cas
dans une discothèque qui a conduit je
crois confinement de 300 personnes du
jour au lendemain avec des risques de
diffusion communautaire c'était le cas
aux états-unis l'allemagne ami henry en
place des règles assez strictes puisque
je crois que la danse il est autorisé en
position assise l'italie a autorisé des
groupes indépendants les uns des autres
à danser lorsqu'ils étaient arrivés
ensemble ou issus de la même famille
vous comprenez bien que chaque pays
essaye de faire comme il peut la france
a pris la décision de ne pas rouvrir la
discothèque en l'état compte tenu de la
situation sanitaire et des risques ce
n'est pas la faute des acteurs du monde
de la nuit
ce n'est pas non plus la faute des
personnes qui danse et qui font la fête
et on peut parfaitement le comprendre
ce n'est là c'est la faute à un virus
c'est la faute à un virus qui circule et
des conditions qui permettent au virus
de se transmettre et de mettre en danger
tout le plan de levée du confinement qui
a été réussie et mis en oeuvre par le
premier ministre alors qu'il n'était pas
encore premier ministre madame la
députée il faut accompagner les acteurs
du monde de la nuit et nous voulons
accompagner les acteurs du monde de la
nuit personne ne peut survivre à la
fermeture d'une activité économique
pendant sept mois vous avez raison mais
le gouvernement l'avez vous remarqué
madame la députée n'a laissé mourir
personne de son activité économique
depuis le début de la crise ni les
salariés avec 12 millions salariés au
chômage partiel ni les artisans ni
indépendant ni les commerçants qui ploie
après mois ont perçu des aides et c'est
tout à fait normal et l'etat sera au
rendez vous pour venir en aide aux
acteurs du monde de la nuit je ne peux
pas répondre à la place du ministre de
l'économie et des finances et de la
relance mais sachez que j'avais demandé
la semaine dernière à ce que
les représentants de la filière soit
reçue à mon ministère par le rentier
trash et de ce qui était alors
secrétaire d'état
nous n'abandonnons pas les acteurs du
monde de la nuit et j'ai conscience
j'ai conscience des fêtes clandestines
j'ai conscience des bars qui ne jouent
pas le jeu
il faut qu'ils aient du contrôle
immersive les chevilles la séance des
questions au gouvernement est terminée
prochaine séance cet après midi à 15
heures suite du projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2020